Let us now speed Hermes the guide, the slayer of Argos, toward O'Gigia Island, so that he can speedily announce your steadfast decision to the nymph of the beautiful braids, that Odysseus, whose mind stands fast, shall make his journey home. For my part, I will embark for Ithaca there to breathe purpose into his son, that I might instill a man's courage within his heart, and to make him call an assembly of the long-haired Ithacans and tell all the suitors to go. Those men who never leave off slaughtering throngs of his sheep and his lumbering twisty-horned cattle. To Sparta, I shall send him and to Sandy Pylos too.
现在，让我们催促向导赫尔墨斯，那位阿尔戈斯的杀手，前往奥吉吉亚岛，让他尽快向那位编着美丽发辫的仙女传达你坚定的决定：意志坚定的奥德修斯，应当踏上归途。至于我，我将启程前往伊萨卡，去激励他的儿子，将男人的勇气注入他的心中，让他召集长发的伊萨卡人，并告诉所有的求婚者离开。那些人从未停止屠宰他成群的绵羊和笨重扭曲的牛群。我将派他前往斯巴达，以及沙地皮洛斯。
To learn whatever he can of his dear father's journey home. And to help him as well to earn a noble renown among men. So that was Dame Edna Reveridge, playing the goddess Athena. And Athena is talking to her father Zeus, King of the Gods, and this is in the first of the 24 books that constitute Homer's great epic, The Odyssey.
去尽可能多地了解他亲爱的父亲回家的旅程。并帮助他赢得人们的崇高声望。刚才那是埃德娜·埃弗里奇夫人，饰演女神雅典娜。雅典娜正在与她的父亲，众神之王宙斯交谈，这出自荷马伟大史诗《奥德赛》二十四卷中的第一卷。
And as we were saying in our first episode, there is something very Australian about the expedition of Odysseus and his men across the Aegean, barbecuing on the beach, drinking unnecessarily, behaving badly, and basically comporting themselves
正如我们在第一集中所说，奥德修斯和他的部下横渡爱琴海的远征中，有一种非常澳大利亚的感觉：在海滩上烧烤，毫无节制地喝酒，行为不端，基本上表现得
like Australians on the beaches of the Dardanelles. And so we felt that Australian voices, Russell Crowe in the last episode across between Kylie Monogue and Dame Edna and this one were at the most appropriate. I was imagining Kylie, I have to say. Right.
就像在达达尼尔海峡海滩上的澳大利亚人一样。所以我们觉得澳大利亚口音——上一集是罗素·克劳，这一集是凯莉·米洛和埃德娜夫人的结合——是最合适的。我不得不说，我当时想象的是凯莉。没错。
It turned into Dame Edna. If I shut my eyes, I could imagine Kylie and then I'd open my eyes and see you and it would all go. Yeah, nice. I mean, a lot of people's fantasy, actually. Anyway, the translation there is by Daniel Mendelson, who's on our bonus episode
结果变成了埃德娜夫人。如果我闭上眼睛，我能想象出凯莉，但当我睁开眼睛看到你时，一切就都变了。是的，不错。我是说，这其实是很多人的幻想。无论如何，刚才的翻译出自丹尼尔·门德尔松，他参加了我们的奖励剧集
for Restis History Club members talking about the Odyssey. Of course, we're doing this series is because the film by Christopher Nolan is out this week. It goes on general release on the 17th. And Tom, I know you've gone online, haven't you, to book your tickets because you don't want to miss out. Is that right?
为“Restis历史俱乐部”的成员讲述《奥德赛》。当然，我们制作这个系列是因为克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影本周上映。它将于17日公映。汤姆，我知道你已经上网订票了，对吧，因为你不想错过。是这样吗？
Actually, I went to the preview. Okay. That's just showing off, isn't it? It's just showing off. It's the sort of boastful behavior that you would expect of a Greek hero, I guess. Yeah, it's a key in behavior. And I will regret it when I end up in the underworld. This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's five.
其实我去了预映场。好吧。那简直是在炫耀，不是吗？那只是在炫耀。我想，这就是你所期望的希腊英雄那种自夸的行为。是的，这是一种典型的行为。当我最终进入冥界时，我会后悔的。本集由劳埃德银行赞助。
house deposit and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth of the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody's listening to Blair and Oasis and looking forward to buying their first houses and that of course takes us to mortgages. Now the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer. 1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may
房屋首付，这是1996年最后一次出现的东西。是的，所以1990年代现在看起来像是一个失落的繁荣与积极的黄金时代，不是吗？想想1997年布莱尔政府上台时的那种热情和兴奋，当时的经济增长，技术发展，那种每个人都在听布莱尔和绿洲乐队，期待着购买他们第一套房子的无尽黄金夏天的感觉，当然，这把我们带到了抵押贷款。现在好消息是，为了向1990年代致敬，劳埃德银行正在为首次购房者提供5000英镑的首付抵押贷款。所以搜索“5K首次购房者”。1996年的平均首次购房者首付基于英国国家统计局数据。受限于个人状况，如果你不按时还款，你的房子可能会
be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments and conditions apply. That's right, it's heating up everyone. The rest is football is on Netflix for the world's biggest tournament and we're officially in the business end. The knockouts are here and don't worry, myself, Alan and Micah are still here every day from New York City, all the debates from the biggest games and a special guest or two for good measure. What a time we're having. Don't miss it.
被收回，且适用相关条件。没错，大家，气氛正在升温。Netflix正在播放《Rest is Football》，这是为了世界上最盛大的锦标赛，我们正式进入了关键阶段。淘汰赛已经到来，别担心，我和阿兰、迈卡每天都会从纽约市为您带来所有关于重大比赛的辩论，还有一两位特别嘉宾助阵。我们度过了一段多么美好的时光。千万别错过。
Twizzlers keep the fun going. Yeah, I know. I just stopped whatever you were listening to to tell you that Twizzlers, keep the fun going. Well, irony isn't my forte, but twisty, chewy, yummy Twizzler sure is. So think of Twizzlers as a little palate cleanser for whatever's queued up, which by the way should be coming very soon. Like any second now. Okay, Twizzlers, time to keep the fun going. So a recap to remind people where we are in the story. In the first episode, we heard how Odysseus, the wiliest, the smartest of all the Greek heroes, fought for 10 years in the Trojan War,
Twizzlers让乐趣持续。是的，我知道。我只是打断了你正在听的内容，告诉你Twizzlers，让乐趣持续。好吧，讽刺不是我的强项，但扭曲、耐嚼、美味的Twizzler绝对是。所以把Twizzlers当作你接下来要听的内容的一点清口剂，顺便说一句，那应该很快就会到来。就像随时都会发生一样。好吧，Twizzlers，是时候让乐趣持续了。那么，回顾一下提醒大家我们故事的进展。在第一集中，我们听到了奥德修斯，所有希腊英雄中最狡猾、最聪明的人，如何在特洛伊战争中战斗了10年，
He was the maestro behind the Trojan horse, that he tries to get home with his men and he is blown fatally off course. And Tom remind us of all his adventures and what happened. So loads of mad adventures, one-eyed giants, beautiful sorceresses. He goes to the underworld meets the ghost of his mother and various of his fallen comrades. And he ends up losing all his fleet. He had 12 ships. They end up completely destroyed. And all his men.
他是特洛伊木马背后的策划者，他试图带着部下回家，却被风吹离了航线，遭遇了致命的打击。汤姆，提醒我们他所有的冒险经历以及发生了什么。所以，大量的疯狂冒险，独眼巨人，美丽的巫女。他去了冥界，见到了他母亲的鬼魂和他各种阵亡的战友。最终他失去了所有的船队。他有12艘船。它们最终被彻底摧毁。还有他所有的部下。
He is the only survivor of the entire expedition. and he has been washed up on the mysterious island of Ogigia, ruled by a nymph, the lady Calypso, that radiant goddess. And on Agigia, he has been kept essentially as Calypso's sex slave for seven long years. And every night he would spend with the nymph doing as she commanded. And every day he would weep for Penelope, his beloved wife, his soulmate. And Agigia is described by Homer as being the Omphalos of the sea, the naval of the sea, a place so remote that Plutarch, who was writing in the second century AD, so centuries after Homer wrote it, would place it five days sail west of Britain. So that would make it, what, Newfoundland, I guess? Yeah, I mean, somewhere on the way to Canada anyway.
他是整个远征队中唯一的幸存者。他被冲到了神秘的奥吉吉亚岛上，那里由一位仙女统治，即那位光芒四射的女神卡吕普索。在奥吉吉亚，他实际上被卡吕普索当作性奴隶关押了整整七年。每天晚上他都要和这位仙女在一起，听从她的命令。每天白天他都会为他心爱的妻子、他的灵魂伴侣佩涅洛佩哭泣。奥吉吉亚被荷马描述为大海的“肚脐”，一个如此偏远的地方，以至于公元二世纪（即荷马写作几个世纪后）写作的普鲁塔克，将其置于英国以西五天的航程处。所以那大概是，什么，纽芬兰吧？是的，我是说，反正是在去加拿大的路上。
Yeah, but I think Plutarch. is wrong because in truth, Agigia is a place that transcends geography and in fact, time, because it's meaning in Greek or Gigios, it means primal before the dawn of time. So essentially, Odysseus has passed into a strange dimension where the conventional rules that govern mortals no longer apply. And he has vanished from the world of humans. And Calypso actually means in Greek she who veils, she who conceals. So it's the same route as Apocalypse, which means an unveiling. So Odysseus can't escape partly because she won't let him go, but also I think because it is impossible for him to get out of this kind of strange dimension that she controls and coordinates.
是的，但我认为普鲁塔克错了，因为事实上，奥吉吉亚是一个超越地理，甚至超越时间的地方，因为它的希腊语含义“Ogigios”意味着原始的，在时间黎明之前。所以本质上，奥德修斯已经进入了一个奇怪的维度，凡人所遵循的常规规则不再适用。他已经从人类世界中消失了。而卡吕普索在希腊语中实际上意味着“遮蔽者”、“隐藏者”。所以它和“启示录”（Apocalypse，意为揭示）有着相同的词根。所以奥德修斯无法逃脱，部分是因为她不让他走，但也因为我认为他不可能从她控制和协调的这种奇怪维度中走出来。
But the reason also why Odysseus can't escape, and people who listen to our first episode may recall this, is because Odysseus very foolishly has offended beside him. who is the god of the sea and he'd done this by blinding his son, the one-eyed giant polyphemus. And so Poseidon, he doesn't necessarily want Odysseus dead. He's perfectly happy to leave him on this kind of island prison with Clipso as the governor.
但奥德修斯无法逃脱的另一个原因，听过我们第一集的听众可能还记得，是因为奥德修斯非常愚蠢地冒犯了波塞冬，他是海神，他通过弄瞎波塞冬的儿子，独眼巨人波吕斐摩斯做到了这一点。所以波塞冬并不一定想要奥德修斯死。他非常乐意把他留在这种以卡吕普索为总督的岛屿监狱里。
And as far as Poseidon is concerned, he can just stay there and rot and never get back home. But Odysseus has a powerful protector of his own, doesn't he? And this is the person who we heard voiced by Dame Edna, at the beginning of the episode. So this is another Olympian, and this is Athena. And she likes Odysseus because she sees him as like-minded, because they're both very wise and clever.
就波塞冬而言，他可以一直待在那里腐烂，永远回不了家。但奥德修斯有他自己强大的保护者，不是吗？这就是我们在本集开头听到由埃德娜夫人配音的那个人。所以这是另一位奥林匹斯神，即雅典娜。她喜欢奥德修斯，因为她认为他志同道合，因为他们都非常聪明睿智。
Yes, I think she sees something of herself in Odysseus. And so during the Trojan War, she had spoken to him. She'd occasionally appeared to him. Over the course of his adventures, she has not appeared to him or spoken to him because she doesn't want to offend Poseidon. Fortunately, however, as the Odyssey opens, Poseidon is in the land of the Ethiopians who are not to be identified with the people who live in what today we call Ethiopia. Their name means people with burned faces, so people on the edges of the world where the sun is at its brightest.
是的，我想她在奥德修斯身上看到了自己的影子。所以在特洛伊战争期间，她曾与他交谈。她偶尔会出现在他面前。在他冒险的过程中，她没有出现或与他交谈，因为她不想冒犯波塞冬。然而幸运的是，当《奥德赛》开篇时，波塞冬正在埃塞俄比亚人的土地上，他们不应与今天我们称之为埃塞俄比亚的人混为一谈。他们的名字意为“面孔被烧焦的人”，即在太阳最强烈的地方，世界边缘的人。
They're blessed, they're noble, they're the kind of people that God would like to spend time having a holiday with. And so Poseidon is away from Olympus. And so this gives Athena her chance. And as we heard in that passage with which we opened, voiced by Kylie Stroke Dame Edna, Athena has a two-prong strategy. So the first is to get Zeus to send Hermes, the messenger of the gods, to a gigia to order Clipso to set Odysseus free. And secondly, Athena herself will go to Ithaca, Odysseus's home island, and there visit Telemachus, Odysseus's son, and basically kind of encourage him to man up
他们是被祝福的，高贵的，是那种神愿意花时间去度假的人。所以波塞冬不在奥林匹斯山上。这给了雅典娜机会。正如我们在开头那段由凯莉/埃德娜夫人配音的片段中所听到的，雅典娜有一个双管齐下的策略。第一，让宙斯派遣众神的信使赫尔墨斯前往奥吉吉亚，命令卡吕普索释放奥德修斯。第二，雅典娜本人将前往伊萨卡，奥德修斯的故乡，去拜访奥德修斯的儿子特勒马科斯，基本上是鼓励他像个男人一样
to stop being so wet. So this is the moment actually where the Odyssey begins, right? Yes. Where the story that we encounter in the book starts with Athena. Yes. Going to see, is it going to see Telemachus? That's the bit that it kicks off with. Is that right? Yes, important for listeners to understand who've not read the book that the epic does not begin with the fall of Troy. It doesn't begin with Odysseus embarking on his adventures. So not basically as we did it in the previous episode.
别再那么软弱了。所以这实际上是《奥德赛》开始的时刻，对吧？是的。我们在书中遇到的故事是从雅典娜开始的。是的。去见，是去见特勒马科斯吗？这是故事开始的部分。是这样吗？是的，对于没读过这本书的听众来说，重要的是要明白，史诗并不是从特洛伊陷落开始的。它不是从奥德修斯开始冒险开始的。所以基本上不像我们在上一集中那样。
It begins with this moment, with Athena going down to see Telemachus. And 10 years have passed since the fall of Troy. So 20 years since Odysseus had left Ithaca. And people may remember that when he'd left Ithaca, Telemachus was just a baby. but now he is a young man. But to be fair to Telemachus, I mean, he is facing a very challenging situation because Odysseus, before he'd left for Troy, had told Penelope, and I quote, once you see our son starting to grow out his beard, marry whomever you wish. In other words, if I'm not back by this point, you should assume that I'm dead. And people know this. And so
它始于这一刻，雅典娜去见特勒马科斯。特洛伊陷落已经过去了10年。所以奥德修斯离开伊萨卡已经20年了。人们可能记得，当他离开伊萨卡时，特勒马科斯还是个婴儿。但现在他已经是一个年轻人了。但公平地说，特勒马科斯确实面临着非常严峻的局面，因为奥德修斯在去特洛伊之前曾告诉佩涅洛佩，我引用：“一旦你看到我们的儿子开始长出胡须，就嫁给你想嫁的人。”换句话说，如果到那时我还没回来，你应该假设我已经死了。人们都知道这一点。所以
Odysseus' hall is now crowded with suitors who are slaughtering Odysseus's, um, cattle and sheep and insulting his household. Penelope, she wants to hold out. She's hopeful that Odysseus will come back. She knows her husband. She's confident he'll come back. And so she doesn't want to marry any of these suitors. And so for years, she's been keeping them at bay with, again, a kind of very famous wheeze. It's a kind of, it matches the Trojan horse, her husband's great weas. And what she had done was she said to them, I will marry one. of you, once I have completed weaving a shroud for Laertes, the father of Odysseus. And so she sat at her loom, weaving at it all day.
奥德修斯的大厅现在挤满了求婚者，他们正在屠宰奥德修斯的牛羊，侮辱他的家庭。佩涅洛佩，她想坚持下去。她希望奥德修斯能回来。她了解她的丈夫。她相信他会回来。所以她不想嫁给这些求婚者中的任何一个。多年来，她一直用一种非常著名的诡计来抵挡他们。这是一种，它与特洛伊木马相媲美，是她丈夫伟大的诡计。她所做的是她对他们说：“我将嫁给你们中的一个，一旦我织完了拉厄耳忒斯（奥德修斯的父亲）的寿衣。”所以她整天坐在织布机前织布。
And then at night, secretly, she would steal down and unpick everything she had done in the day. Right. And so the suit is a thing. This shroud is taking a long time. It's taken about five years. But in the end, the scheme is betrayed by one of Penelope's servant girls, one of her maids. And so the scheme is rumbled. But at this point, Penelope is still holding out.
然后到了晚上，她会偷偷溜下来，拆掉她白天所做的一切。没错。所以求婚者们想，这件寿衣花的时间太长了。已经花了大约五年了。但最终，这个计划被佩涅洛佩的一个女仆出卖了。所以这个计划被识破了。但在这一点上，佩涅洛佩仍然在坚持。
You know, she doesn't want to give in. And Telemachus also is kind of backing her. But he's just a young man. You know, he hasn't had his father around. He's not kind of trained in the ways of warfare and whiliness and all of that. He's very, very young and inexperienced. And so this is why Athena has decided to visit him, to offer him the kind of advice and encouragement that he hasn't been getting from his father because his father is absent.
你知道，她不想屈服。特勒马科斯也在某种程度上支持她。但他只是个年轻人。你知道，他没有父亲在身边。他没有受过战争和狡诈等方面的训练。他非常非常年轻且缺乏经验。所以这就是为什么雅典娜决定拜访他，为他提供他因为父亲缺席而没有得到的建议和鼓励。
She disguises herself, doesn't she, as an old friend of Odysseus, with the excellent name of Mentor. Yes, she's literally his mentor. Yeah. And when Mentor arrives, Telemachus is very courteous, he's very generous, but Telemachus is extremely embarrassed. It's basically this massive kind of, it's basically like a stag party that's got. Yeah, they're all wearing plastic breasts and covering each other with shaving foam naked. Yeah. It's basically weather spoons at Luton Airport, you know, 8 o'clock in the morning.
她伪装成奥德修斯的一位老朋友，名字叫门托尔。是的，她实际上就是他的导师。是的。当门托尔到达时，特勒马科斯非常有礼貌，非常慷慨，但特勒马科斯感到非常尴尬。这基本上是一场巨大的，这基本上就像一场单身派对。是的，他们都戴着塑料乳房，赤身裸体地互相涂抹剃须膏。是的。这基本上就是卢顿机场的威瑟斯彭酒吧，你知道，早上8点。
People are absolutely off their faces already. Like, there's a lot, there's all kinds of bans. So it's miserable for Portolemachus. So Athena cheers him up, first of all, by saying, actually, I think, you know, I think it's okay. I think your dad is alive. And I think he's going to be coming back home soon. And she then says, you should stand up for yourself.
人们已经完全喝醉了。所以这对可怜的特勒马科斯来说很痛苦。所以雅典娜首先安慰他，说：“其实，我认为，我认为没关系。我认为你父亲还活着。而且我认为他很快就会回家。”然后她说，你应该为自己挺身而出。
You should show your independence. And you could do this in a couple of ways. So you could summon an assembly of all the people of Ithaca and publicly make a stand in front of them against the suitors. And then when you've done this, that you could go and visit some of Odysseus's old mates, some of, you know, some of his comrades from the Trojan War and find out what they know. And then, to quote Homer, so saying, Athena went off, she of the bright owl eyes, just as a bird will fly off in a flash and into
你应该展现你的独立性。你可以通过几种方式做到这一点。你可以召集所有伊萨卡人开会，在他们面前公开反对求婚者。当你这样做之后，你可以去拜访奥德修斯的一些老朋友，一些，你知道，他在特洛伊战争中的战友，看看他们知道些什么。然后，引用荷马的话：“说完，雅典娜走了，那位有着明亮猫头鹰眼睛的女神，就像一只鸟闪电般飞走，进入了
his heart, she put fierceness and strength. And this fierceness and strength, as we've been saying, is something that hadn't previously been evident in Telemachus. And so the suitors, he holds this public assembly for the Ithacons, as Athena had advised. And the suitors go there and they shout it down. But they are startled that Telemachus has had the initiative and the gumption to call it and a little bit worried about this sudden display of kind of character and independence. And even Penelope is surprised by the way in which her son is suddenly showing a kind of assertiveness. So that's a marker that he's laid down for the suitors. And then he heads off for the mainland.
他的心中，她注入了凶猛和力量。”这种凶猛和力量，正如我们所说，是特勒马科斯之前没有表现出来的。所以求婚者们，他按照雅典娜的建议为伊萨卡人召开了公开会议。求婚者们去了那里并大声喧哗。但他们惊讶于特勒马科斯竟然有主动性和胆量召集会议，并且对这种突然表现出的性格和独立性感到有点担心。甚至佩涅洛佩也对她儿子突然表现出的那种果断感到惊讶。所以这是他为求婚者设下的一个标志。然后他前往大陆。
And again, he does it without telling them what he's doing. He slips away unnoticed. And he heads off to the mainland of Greece, to the Peloponnese. And there he's going to visit two of his father's old comrades in arms. And the first of these is a guy called Nestor, who is the king of Pilos on the west coast of the Peloponnese. And he had been the oldest warrior who'd fought at trial. fabulously ancient and doddery and long white beard and all of that. And unfortunately, Nestor has no idea where Odysseus is, so he's not much use.
而且他再次在没有告诉他们他在做什么的情况下就走了。他悄悄溜走了。他前往希腊大陆，前往伯罗奔尼撒半岛。在那里，他将拜访他父亲的两位老战友。第一位是一个叫内斯特的人，他是伯罗奔尼撒半岛西海岸皮洛斯的国王。他是参加特洛伊战争的最年长的战士。极其古老，步履蹒跚，留着长长的白胡子等等。不幸的是，内斯特根本不知道奥德修斯在哪里，所以他没什么用。
But he says it's like he's vanished off the face of the earth. I've heard no rumours about him whatsoever. But he kind of cheers Telemachus up by telling him war stories. You know, Nestor's an old man and so the joke is that this is all he ever does is tell stories about the good old days. But these are stories that feature Odysseus being an absolute legend. I mean, kind of literally. And he tells stories about how brave Odysseus had been, how clever, and how close he had
但他说是的，他好像从地球表面消失了。我根本没听到关于他的任何传闻。但他通过讲战争故事来安慰特勒马科斯。你知道，内斯特是个老人，所以笑话是，他所做的就是讲关于美好旧时光的故事。但这些故事里，奥德修斯是一个绝对的传奇。我是说，字面意义上的。他讲述了奥德修斯是多么勇敢，多么聪明，以及他与雅典娜有多么亲近。
been to Athena. So Telemachus had seen Menthol turn into a bird and flash off. So it's, you know, cogs in his brain are starting to work thinking maybe Athena is on the scene. And certainly the effect of Nestor and his conversation is to make Telemachus feel proud to be the son of such a man and make him want to be kind of worthy of such a father. And so from Pilos, Telemachus then heads inland to Spartan. where the king is Menelaus, and he is the husband of Helen, whose abduction had led to the entire war. And Helen, when she comes in to join Menelaus and Telemachus in the great feasting hall,
所以特勒马科斯看到了门托尔变成一只鸟飞走了。所以，你知道，他大脑里的齿轮开始转动，心想也许雅典娜就在现场。当然，内斯特和他的谈话的效果是让特勒马科斯为成为这样一个人的儿子感到自豪，并让他想要变得配得上这样的父亲。所以从皮洛斯，特勒马科斯然后前往斯巴达内陆。那里的国王是墨涅拉俄斯，他是海伦的丈夫，海伦的被劫导致了整场战争。当海伦进来加入墨涅拉俄斯和特勒马科斯在盛大的宴会厅时，
she immediately recognizes him as Odysse's son, because Helen is the daughter of Zeus. She has a kind of witchy quality. She has kind of supernatural powers. And Helen sits with Telemachus, and she tells him a story about Adiscus. how back in the days of the Trojan war, he had infiltrated Troy disguised as an old beggar, and that he had disguised himself so effectively that he'd had himself lashed across his back, like a slave, so that when he came into Troy, people could see these marks, and it would have seemed impossible to the Trojans to think that this could actually have been a great hero.
她立刻认出他是奥德修斯的儿子，因为海伦是宙斯的女儿。她有一种巫婆般的特质。她有一种超自然的力量。海伦和特勒马科斯坐在一起，她给他讲了一个关于奥德修斯的故事。在特洛伊战争时期，他曾伪装成一个老乞丐潜入特洛伊，他伪装得如此有效，以至于他让人把他的背部鞭打得像个奴隶，这样当他进入特洛伊时，人们就能看到这些伤痕，特洛伊人会觉得这不可能是一个伟大的英雄。
And Helen boasted to Lemicus, I alone saw through his disguise. And of course, she could have betrayed him, but she truly, chooses not to. And she says, for by then my heart had long since been bent on going back home. And Menelaus then tells a story also about Odysseus, how they've built the Trojan horse and the Greek heroes, the Achaean heroes, have hidden themselves inside the great belly of the horse. And then Helen had come down to them and started calling out in the voices of their wives. So again, this is the kind of the witchy quality of Helen. And it's undermining her claim actually that she was now on the Greek side.
海伦向特勒马科斯吹嘘：“只有我看穿了他的伪装。”当然，她本可以出卖他，但她确实选择不这样做。她说：“因为那时我的心早已倾向于回家。”然后墨涅拉俄斯也讲了一个关于奥德修斯的故事，关于他们如何建造特洛伊木马，希腊英雄，阿凯亚英雄，如何把自己藏在马的巨大肚子里。然后海伦来到他们身边，开始用他们妻子的声音呼唤。所以这又是海伦那种巫婆般的特质。这实际上削弱了她声称自己现在站在希腊一边的说法。
I was about to say she's playing both sides. Yeah, she is playing both sides. Yeah. And the men inside the horse, they hear that what seems to be their wives, they're so homesick, they're so longing for their wives that lots of them want to kind of call out and reply. But Odysseus knows what's going on. He keeps very silent. He keeps them motionless.
我正要说她在两边下注。是的，她在两边下注。是的。马肚子里的男人们听到那似乎是他们妻子的声音，他们太想家了，太渴望他们的妻子了，以至于他们中的许多人想呼唤并回应。但奥德修斯知道发生了什么。他保持沉默。他让他们一动不动。
He puts his hand over the mouths of those who look as if they're about to call out. And these two stories, the story firstly told by Helen, then by men of the men of the Elias, again, they're illustrating the qualities of Odysseus, how intelligent he is, how bold, how daring, and also how self-disciplined he is. But the most crucial thing that Menelaus tells Telemachus is that he does actually have news of Odysseus. And this is because he had ended up on his journey back from Troy in Egypt. And there he had captured the old man of the sea, he's called Proteus, who is a kind of shepherd of seals. has all kinds of weird supernatural powers, able to change his shape. So that's where the word protean comes from. But Menelaus had captured him and held him despite all this shape-shifting, and finally had got Proteus to reveal to him all kinds of things. And among the things that Proteus had revealed is the fact that Odysseus is alive. And to quote what Proteus had told Menelaus, I saw Odysseus on an island, his eyes brimming over with tears in the halls of the
他捂住那些看起来要呼唤的人的嘴。这两个故事，首先由海伦讲述，然后由墨涅拉俄斯讲述，再次说明了奥德修斯的品质，他有多聪明，多大胆，多勇敢，以及他有多么自律。但墨涅拉俄斯告诉特勒马科斯最关键的事情是，他确实有奥德修斯的消息。这是因为他在从特洛伊回来的路上最终到了埃及。在那里，他抓住了“海中老人”，他叫普罗透斯，他是某种海豹牧人。拥有各种奇怪的超自然力量，能够改变他的形状。所以“多变的”（protean）这个词就是由此而来。但墨涅拉俄斯抓住了他，尽管他有这种变形能力，还是抓住了他，最终让普罗透斯向他揭示了各种事情。普罗透斯向墨涅拉俄斯揭示的事情中，包括奥德修斯还活着的事实。引用普罗透斯告诉墨涅拉俄斯的话：“我看到奥德修斯在一个岛上，他的眼睛里充满了泪水，在仙女卡吕普索的宫殿里，她强迫他留在那里，他无法回到他父亲的土地上。”所以现在特勒马科斯知道他还活着。这就是我们上次离开奥德修斯的地方，我们留下了悬念：他能从卡吕普索的怀抱中逃脱吗？我很高兴地说答案是肯定的，这归功于雅典娜，不是吗？因为基本上我们说过她做了两件事：她去找特勒马科斯，但她也去找宙斯。是的，她的父亲。雅典娜是宙斯最喜欢的女儿。波塞冬不在。所以雅典娜基本上是在奥林匹斯山上到处游说，试图为奥德修斯解决问题，并纠缠她的父亲。最终宙斯向她屈服，并派遣众神的信使赫尔墨斯从奥林匹斯山顶一路前往奥吉吉亚岛，这个大海的肚脐。当赫尔墨斯到达那里时，他告诉卡吕普索：“你必须放奥德修斯走。”她对此大发雷霆。赫尔墨斯说：“不要激怒宙斯。”你知道，不要让他生气。所以卡吕普索非常不情愿地允许奥德修斯建造一艘船。她给了他补给，说：“好吧，你可以走了。”但在他走之前，她给了他一个巨大的提议。
nymph calypso who is holding him there by compulsion he is not able to return to the land of his fathers so now telemachus knows he is alive so that's where we left adesius last time and we left on the cliffhanger is he ever going to escape from the arms of calypso and i'm happy to say that the answer is yes and this is down to athena isn't it because basically we said that she does two things she goes to telemachus but she also goes to see zeus yes her father father and Athena is Zeus's favorite daughter. Poseidon is absent. And so Athena is basically kind of sassing around Olympus trying to sort things out for Odysseus and hassling her father. And finally Zeus gives in to her and sends Hermes, the messenger of the gods, down from the
宁芙卡吕普索强行将他留在那儿，他无法回到祖国，所以现在特勒马科斯知道他还活着。这就是我们上次讲到奥德修斯的地方，我们停在了一个悬念上：他能从卡吕普索的怀抱中逃脱吗？我很高兴地说答案是肯定的，这要归功于雅典娜，对吧？因为我们基本上说过她做了两件事，她去找了特勒马科斯，但也去见了宙斯，是的，她的父亲，而雅典娜是宙斯最宠爱的女儿。波塞冬不在。所以雅典娜基本上是在奥林匹斯山上四处奔走，试图为奥德修斯解决问题，并缠着她的父亲。最终宙斯向她妥协，派遣众神的使者赫尔墨斯从
summit of Olympus all the way to the island of Agigia, this naval of the sea. And when Hermes arrives there, he tells Clipso, you've got to let Odysseus go. And she had a clip. Clip, So he has a massive strope about it. And Hermes says, do not provoke Zeus to anger. You know, do not make him angry. And so very reluctantly, Calypso permits Odysseus to build a boat. And she gives him provisions and says, okay, you can go. But before he goes, she makes him a great offer.
奥林匹斯山之巅一路前往奥吉吉亚岛，这个大地的肚脐。当赫尔墨斯到达那里时，他告诉卡吕普索，你必须放奥德修斯走。她对此大发雷霆。赫尔墨斯说，不要激怒宙斯。你知道，不要让他生气。于是，卡吕普索非常不情愿地允许奥德修斯建造一艘船。她给了他补给，说，好吧，你可以走了。但在他离开之前，她给了他一个巨大的提议。
And she offers him the gift of immortality if he will stay with her. And listeners may remember that in the previous episode, we talked about how Odysseus had met with Achilles. the great hero who is now just a kind of a shadow in the underworld. And Achilles had basically said, you know, life is so much better than death that you should embrace any opportunity you can to perpetuate it. So this is a massive, massive offer. But Odysseus turns it down. And it's one of the great eulogies in ancient literature to the joys and the comforts of marital love.
如果他愿意留下来，她就给他永生的礼物。听众可能记得在上一集中，我们谈到了奥德修斯是如何见到阿喀琉斯的。那位伟大的英雄现在只是冥界里的一个影子。阿喀琉斯基本上说过：“你知道，活着比死亡好得多，所以你应该抓住任何机会来延续它。”所以这是一个巨大、巨大的提议。但奥德修斯拒绝了。这是古代文学中对婚姻之爱带来的快乐和安慰的最伟大的颂歌之一。
It has to be said there aren't actually that many. And it begins, it doesn't sound like a unity to his wife, it has to be said, but it kind of pivots. So, Odysseus says to Clipsoe, look at my wise Penelope. She falls far short of you, your beauty, your stature. But she is mortal, after all. She's not a goddess, so you'd expect that. You, you never age or die. Nevertheless, I long, I pine in all my days to travel home and see the dawn of my return. So he would rather live with Penelope and die than live with Clipso. and live forever. And it's a kind of moving moment, I think. Not many wives who would welcome that tribute to themselves that begins with them saying, she falls far short of you. Anyway, Odysseus sets off from a gigia,
必须说，实际上并没有那么多。它开始时，必须说，听起来不像对他妻子的赞美，但它发生了一些转折。所以，奥德修斯对卡吕普索说：“看看我聪明的佩涅洛佩。她的美貌、她的身材都远不如你。但毕竟她是凡人。她不是女神，所以你预料到了。你，你永远不会变老或死亡。尽管如此，我渴望，我日夜思念着回家，看到我归来的黎明。”所以他宁愿和佩涅洛佩一起生活并死去，也不愿和卡吕普索一起生活并永生。我认为这是一个感人的时刻。没有多少妻子会欢迎那种以“她远不如你”开头的对自己的致敬。无论如何，奥德修斯从奥吉吉亚出发，
and well, these things always end up going one way, don't they? But actually, at first, it's a bit like a Titanic. Everyone talks about the bit where it went wrong, but no one talks about the first couple of days. So in this case, the first 17 days of the voyage or a triumph, but then on the 18th day of the voyage Poseidon is on his way back from the land of the Ethiopians
嗯，这些事情总是以一种方式结束，不是吗？但实际上，起初，这有点像泰坦尼克号。每个人都谈论它出错的部分，但没人谈论最初的几天。所以在这个案例中，航行的前17天是胜利的，但在航行的第18天，波塞冬正在从埃塞俄比亚人的土地回来的路上。
and he sees Odysseus below him doesn't he? So Poseidon is in the sky Yeah and it's just this tiny little dot but he's a god I mean of course he can recognise him he's furious about it and so he strikes the sea with his trident churns it up
他看到了他下方的奥德修斯，不是吗？所以波塞冬在天空中。是的，他只是一个小点，但他是一个神，我是说，当然他能认出他。他对此非常愤怒，所以他用三叉戟击打大海，搅动它。
pulverises Odysseus' raft all the gifts that he's been given by Calypso all his provisions even his clothes he loses them all So he's now kind of naked, literally naked in the salty, boiling sea, almost drowns. There's an island ahead. He's almost smashed onto the rocks by the waves.
粉碎了奥德修斯的木筏，卡吕普索给他的所有礼物，他所有的补给，甚至他的衣服，他都失去了。所以他现在有点赤身裸体，字面意义上的赤身裸体，在咸涩、沸腾的大海中，差点淹死。前面有一个岛。他差点被海浪撞到岩石上。
And in fact, had it not been for Athena, who personally intervenes to save him, he would have been killed. But as it is, with the assistance of the goddess, he is able to crawl himself up onto a sandy beach. And he totters up into a nearby wood. and there's kind of leaves scattered around everywhere. So he hides himself under the leaves and understandably collapses, falls completely asleep and sleeps for who knows how long. But then abruptly, he is woken by the sound of a ball splashing into a pond and the sound of girls shouting and giggling. And obviously, when you've been through a series of adventures that involve giants devouring your men or spanishing, spear on you in harbours or whatever. I mean, these are these are the kind of things that you want to hear.
事实上，如果不是雅典娜亲自干预救了他，他早就死了。但事实是，在女神的帮助下，他能够爬上一个沙滩。他摇摇晃晃地走进附近的一片树林。到处都是散落的叶子。所以他把自己藏在叶子下面，可以理解地崩溃了，完全睡着了，睡了谁知道多久。但随后，他突然被一个球溅入池塘的声音和女孩们尖叫和咯咯笑的声音吵醒。显然，当你经历了一系列涉及巨人吞噬你的部下，或者在港口向你投掷长矛之类的冒险后，我是说，这些是你想要听到的事情。
He's still dreading the worst because he's gone through so many terrible experiences. But he thinks, well, maybe, you know, they're just girls. Maybe it's all right. And also he's desperately hungry. He's desperately thirsty. And so he picks up a kind of a branch with leaves on, a bit like Adam in the Garden of Eden. He uses it to conceal his nakedness. And he steps out and emerges from the wood. And in a clearing, it's the most domestic scene imaginable. It is a group of girls doing the laundry. And they look around and see what seems to be this awful kind of briny pervert, start naked, who stepped out from the woods, like a kind of flasher.
他仍然担心最坏的情况，因为他经历了太多可怕的经历。但他想，好吧，你知道，她们只是女孩。也许没关系。而且他非常饿，非常渴。所以他捡起一根带叶子的树枝，有点像伊甸园里的亚当。他用它来遮盖自己的裸体。他走出来，从树林里出来。在空地上，这是你能想象到的最居家、最温馨的场景。这是一群正在洗衣服的女孩。她们环顾四周，看到了一个看起来像这种可怕的、咸湿的变态，赤身裸体，从树林里走出来，像个暴露狂。
And they understandably scream and run away. But one of the girls does stay and bravely stands her ground. And Odysseus addresses her from a distance. He doesn't want to frighten her. And he talks to her with absolutely perfectly pitch flattery. So he compares her to Artemis, the daughter of mighty Zeus. And he narrates his ordeals and then he appeals to her for help. And finally, and I love this moment, and I think it's clearly betraying his own longing for Penelope.
她们可以理解地尖叫着跑开了。但其中一个女孩留了下来，勇敢地站稳了脚跟。奥德修斯从远处向她致意。他不想吓到她。他用绝对完美的奉承话与她交谈。所以他把她比作强大的宙斯的女儿阿尔忒弥斯。他讲述了自己的磨难，然后请求她的帮助。最后，我喜欢这个时刻，我认为这清楚地暴露了他自己对佩涅洛佩的渴望。
He's, you know, he's seeing this girl and he's thinking of his own family. And he wishes her a happy marriage. And he says, for there's nothing as powerful. powerful or as great as when a husband and wife united by oneness of mind in their thinking, keep their home together, a great bane to their enemies, a blessing to their friends, and their renown is on everyone's lips. And Sadie and I had that at our wedding. Oh, nice.
他，你知道，他看到这个女孩，他想到了自己的家人。他祝愿她婚姻幸福。他说：“因为没有什么比夫妻在思想上达成一致，共同维持家园更强大、更伟大的了，这对他们的敌人来说是一个巨大的祸害，对他们的朋友来说是一个祝福，他们的名声在每个人的嘴边。”我和萨迪在我们的婚礼上就有这个。哦，不错。
Which we had in a church. But important to emphasize, this is very much not a Christian ideal of marriage. This is an ideal of marriage in a world in which it is households, rather than individuals who are being joined. And so to be a bane of one's enemies, a blessing to one's friends, this is a dream that's particularly suited to royal couples because obviously the whole health of a city of a kingdom
我们在教堂里举行的。但重要的是要强调，这绝不是一种基督教的婚姻理想。这是一种在家庭而非个人被结合的世界里的婚姻理想。所以成为敌人的祸害，朋友的祝福，这是一个特别适合皇室夫妇的梦想，因为显然一个城市、一个王国的整个健康状况
can depend on it. And as it turns out, Odysse's words are perfectly suited to the young girl that he has addressed them to because the girl that he is addressing is not an ogress, not a witch, not a ghost, but a mortal princess. So the name of this princess is Norsekeia. She's the daughter we told of Alkinos the great-hearted. And in his hands like the power and might of the Feitians.
都可能取决于它。事实证明，奥德修斯的言辞非常适合他所称呼的那个年轻女孩，因为他所称呼的女孩不是女妖，不是巫婆，不是鬼魂，而是一位凡人公主。所以这位公主的名字是瑙西卡。她是慷慨的阿尔基诺斯的女儿。在他手中掌握着费埃基亚人的力量和威力。
And who are these people? So the Feysians, to the degree that the Odyssey offers one, is a kind of a vision of an ideal society. So Norsekaia's parents, the king and queen of the fysians, Alkinnos, the king, they are wise and generous. They have no idea who Odysseus is, but they greet him with great kindness and hospitality. So this kind of this great quality of xenia, which is so important to the Greeks, welcoming strangers with hospitality. They have kind of perfect microclimate. So their fruit, their vines, their vegetables are always in season. There's no winter.
这些人是谁？所以费埃基亚人，在《奥德赛》提供的范围内，是一种理想社会的愿景。所以瑙西卡的父母，费埃基亚人的国王和王后，阿尔基诺斯国王，他们是明智和慷慨的。他们不知道奥德修斯是谁，但他们以极大的善意和好客迎接他。所以这种“好客”（xenia）的伟大品质，对希腊人来说非常重要，欢迎陌生人。他们有完美的微气候。所以他们的水果、葡萄藤、蔬菜总是当季的。没有冬天。
And they have kind of incredible 1950s science fiction style labor-saving devices. So kind of robotic guard dogs made of gold and silver. And they have ships powered by what sounds a little light AI. Wow. Kind of that's free thinking. They can think faster than any human being. and these ships can travel at a completely miraculous speed. It can kind of travel the length of the Mediterranean.
他们有某种不可思议的1950年代科幻风格的省力设备。比如用金银制成的机器人看门狗。他们有由听起来有点像人工智能驱动的船只。哇。那种是自由思考的。它们思考的速度比任何人类都快。这些船只可以以一种完全奇迹般的速度航行。它可以航行地中海的长度。
Self-sailing ships. Self-sailing ships, yeah. So, again, it's this familiar thing that we were talking about in the first episode, that you have the fantastical element of an island, but then also there are points of similarity with actual islands that exist in the Mediterranean. Right. And so to Homer's original audience, the location and the description of the kind of physical geography of Faisha,
自动航行的船。自动航行的船，是的。所以，这又是我们在第一集中谈到的那个熟悉的事情，你有一个岛屿的奇幻元素，但也有与地中海实际存在的岛屿相似的点。没错。所以对于荷马的原始听众来说，费埃基亚的物理地理位置和描述，
made it seem like it was the island of Kukaira, which is now Kofu. And we did a bonus with Alex Preston about this for club members going to listen to that. And as we've said, Nauticaea, you know, this princess who's doing the laundry and playing, you know, with the ball with her friends and stuff. I mean, this is a world away from the island of Clipso or Circe or whatever. And most amazingly of all, and it's one of the great kind of postmodern moments in the Odyssey. There is a bard at Alkinuas's court who seems like Homer himself. So Homer traditionally is said to be blind and this guy is blind. And it may well be that that description is what gives rise to the legend that Homer was blind.
使它看起来像是科孚岛，也就是现在的科孚。我们为俱乐部成员制作了一个关于这个的奖励节目，亚历克斯·普雷斯顿谈论了这个，去听听那个。正如我们所说，瑙西卡，你知道，这个正在洗衣服、和朋友玩球之类的公主。我是说，这与卡吕普索或喀耳刻的岛屿完全是两个世界。最令人惊奇的是，这是《奥德赛》中伟大的后现代时刻之一。在阿尔基诺斯的宫廷里有一位吟游诗人，看起来就像荷马本人。所以荷马传统上被认为是盲人，而这家伙也是盲人。很有可能这种描述导致了荷马是盲人的传说。
And he's inspired by the muses, as Homer was thought to be. And he reduces grown men to tears with the power and the pathos of his epic singing. And this blind poet sings to the court at Fascia. and among the men at this course, of course, is Odysseus himself. And the bard is singing about the Trojan War and about the feats of arms that Odysseus himself had performed at Troy. And Odysseus weeps to hear them. You know, it's noticed.
他受到缪斯的启发，就像人们认为荷马受到启发一样。他用他史诗般歌唱的力量和感染力让成年男人流泪。这位盲诗人为费埃基亚的宫廷歌唱。在这些宫廷的人中，当然有奥德修斯本人。吟游诗人唱的是特洛伊战争，唱的是奥德修斯本人在特洛伊所表现出的武功。奥德修斯听到这些流下了眼泪。你知道，这被注意到了。
And so, you know, Alkinna says, stranger, why do you weep? And Odysseus finally reveals who he is. And it is this which prompts him to tell the story of his adventures. So the Lotus Eaters and the Cyclops and everything. So this is the narrative that we told in episode one. So it's brilliantly, brilliantly meta. You were saying that it's kind of postmodern book. And of course, there's loads of stories within stories, aren't there in the Odyssey?
所以，你知道，阿尔基诺斯说：“陌生人，你为什么哭泣？”奥德修斯终于透露了他的身份。正是这一点促使他讲述了他的冒险故事。所以食莲人、独眼巨人等等。所以这就是我们在第一集中讲述的叙事。所以它非常、非常巧妙地运用了元叙事。你说这是一种后现代的书。当然，在《奥德赛》中有很多故事中的故事，不是吗？
That's how it works. So you can see what it would appeal to a filmmaker. Yeah. You know, flashbacks and things like that. Yes. And I guess particularly one like Christopher Nolan, who loves all these kind of games with time and so on. And so it is, you know, he tells his story.
这就是它的运作方式。所以你可以看出它为什么会吸引电影制作人。是的。你知道，闪回之类的东西。是的。我想特别是像克里斯托弗·诺兰这样的人，他喜欢所有这些关于时间的游戏等等。所以，你知道，他讲述了他的故事。
And at the end, everyone is silent, held absolutely spellbound. all through the shadowy palace. And Alkinuos is the king, is so moved that he says, well, we've got to get you back to your home. We've got to get you back to Ithaca. And so at last, 20 years have gone by, but now Odysseus is ready to go home. And Alkinous loads one of these kind of free sailing AI powered ships with all kinds of gifts. And Odysseus boards it. and he curls up and he falls asleep and the ship speeds across the seas, miraculous power.
最后，每个人都沉默了，完全被迷住了。整个阴影笼罩的宫殿。阿尔基诺斯是国王，他非常感动，他说：“好吧，我们必须让你回到你的家。我们必须让你回到伊萨卡。”所以终于，20年过去了，但现在奥德修斯准备回家了。阿尔基诺斯用各种礼物装满了这些自由航行的人工智能驱动的船只之一。奥德修斯登上了它。他蜷缩起来，睡着了，船以奇迹般的力量在海上飞驰。
The morning star rises. And as the morning star rises, this ship reaches Ithaca at last. And the fysian crew lift the still sleeping Odysseus out of the ship. And they place him and all the gifts that Alcinois had given him on a beach under an olive tree. and then we're told they themselves went back speeding homewards. And so it is in the most unglamorous, the most kind of anticlimactic manner possible that Odysseus returns to Ithaca. And as had been foretold, he has done so not on his own ship, but on someone else's ship. And he has arrived there alone, but he is at home at last.
晨星升起。当晨星升起时，这艘船终于到达了伊萨卡。费埃基亚船员把仍在熟睡的奥德修斯从船上抬了下来。他们把他和阿尔基诺斯给他的所有礼物放在橄榄树下的海滩上，然后我们被告知他们自己加速回国了。所以，奥德修斯以最不迷人、最反高潮的方式回到了伊萨卡。正如预言的那样，他不是坐自己的船，而是坐别人的船。他独自到达了那里，但他终于到家了。
But is this the end of his troubles? Spoiler alert, it is not. His troubles are only just beginning. We'll find out why after the break. This episode is brought to you by Hamilton the musical. Tom, when we think of America's founding fathers, we think of dusty portraits, grim-faced men with terrible teeth, and of course unpaid tax bills, don't we?
但这真的是他麻烦的终结吗？剧透警告，并不是。他的麻烦才刚刚开始。休息后我们会找出原因。本集由音乐剧《汉密尔顿》赞助。汤姆，当我们想到美国的开国元勋时，我们会想到尘土飞扬的肖像，表情严峻、牙齿糟糕的男人，当然还有未付的税单，不是吗？
That's right, but what we don't see is the struggle, the resentment, the euphoria, the love, the rapping, all in the name of American independence. 250 years ago. That's what we loved, isn't it, about Lynn Manuel Miranda's award-winning musical Hamilton, which we went to see with our team just the other day. It brought the story of those turbulent years to life beyond the walls of a museum from the room where it happened.
没错，但我们没有看到的是斗争、怨恨、欣快、爱、说唱，所有这些都是以美国独立的名义。250年前。这就是我们所爱的，不是吗，关于林-曼努埃尔·米兰达获奖音乐剧《汉密尔顿》，我们前几天和我们的团队一起去看了。它让那些动荡岁月的历史在博物馆墙外鲜活起来，从它发生的地方。
It's an incredible depiction of the life and legacy of Alexander Hamilton, who was George Washington's right-hand man, an incredibly politically significant figure. It is an absolute cultural phenomenon, and you can experience it right now at London's Victoria Palace Theatre. Book tickets today at Hamilton Musical.com forward slash London. This episode is brought to you by Accenture. When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows.
这是对亚历山大·汉密尔顿生平与遗产的精彩描绘，他是乔治·华盛顿的得力助手，也是一位极具政治影响力的人物。这是一部绝对的文化现象级作品，你现在就可以在伦敦维多利亚宫剧院体验它。请访问 HamiltonMusical.com/London 预订门票。本集由埃森哲赞助播出。当你的广告运营不同步时，其他一切都会随之受影响。
Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales, using automation, analytics and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery and access better data across the business. The result? Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most. Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify. Hey, y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair.
Spotify 和埃森哲正在合作重塑广告销售的节奏，利用自动化、分析和更智能的工作流程来简化广告投放，并获取整个业务中更好的数据。结果如何？减少了运营时间，增加了将品牌与最重要的时刻和粉丝群体联系起来的时间。了解更多信息，请访问 Accenture.com/Spotify。大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表 Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想“万一呢”？比如，万一它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从 Wayfair 订购。
With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit wayfair.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. Zeus whose shield is thunder, standing by me always in every combat mission, no maneuver of mine slips by you. Now again, give me your best support, Athena, comrade. So that was Odysseus talking to Athena. Now that's actually not from the Odyssey. It's from the Iliad as translated by Robert Fagels. So it perfectly illustrates how close the two of them had been in the Trojan War, how they'd been secretly communicating with each other. She'd spoken to him, for example, in the
有了 Wayfair，就没有“万一”。只有你喜欢的风格和值得信赖的品质。请访问 wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。宙斯，你的盾牌是雷霆，在每一次战斗任务中都站在我身边，我没有任何动作能逃过你的眼睛。现在，雅典娜，我的战友，再次给我最好的支持。刚才那是奥德修斯在和雅典娜对话。其实那不是出自《奥德赛》，而是出自罗伯特·法格尔斯翻译的《伊利亚特》。它完美地说明了他们在特洛伊战争中有多亲密，他们是如何秘密交流的。例如，她曾对他说话，在
that passage that we were just quoting, she speaks to him through the kind of cry of a heron. But here's the twist. Then during the voyage, for the 10 years of the voyage, that communication basically died. She kept silent because she didn't want to offend her fellow Olympian Poseidon. But now at last Tom, Athena is back. She absolutely is. And to have her on the scene for Odysseus is obviously brilliant news. But remember, at this point, he doesn't know where he is.
我们刚才引用的那段话中，她通过苍鹭的叫声对他说话。但转折来了。在随后的十年航行中，这种交流基本上中断了。她保持沉默，因为她不想冒犯她的奥林匹斯同僚波塞冬。但现在，汤姆，雅典娜终于回来了。确实如此。对于奥德修斯来说，她在现场显然是个绝佳的消息。但请记住，此时他并不知道自己身在何处。
So just to give people a reminder where we are at the story. Odysse's wife, Penelope, is in his palace. There are 108 suitors by this point, all kind of competing for her hand in marriage. And they are all of them kind of insolent, violent, and, in fact, murderous. And I say murderous because, people may remember that Telemachus had gone off on his voyage to see Nesta and Menelaus on the mainland of Greece. He is now sailing back from mainland Greece to Ithaca. And the plan of the suitors, now that they've rumbled where he's gone, is to ambush and kill him at sea
为了让大家回顾一下故事进展到哪里了。奥德修斯的妻子佩涅洛佩正在他的宫殿里。此时有 108 名求婚者，都在争夺与她结婚的机会。他们都傲慢无礼、暴力，甚至可以说是杀人犯。我之所以说杀人犯，是因为大家可能还记得特勒马科斯曾去大陆拜访涅斯托尔和墨涅拉俄斯。他现在正从希腊大陆航行回伊萨卡。求婚者们在发现他的去向后，计划在海上伏击并杀害他
before he can reach Ithaca. So that's bad news for Telemachus. Meanwhile, Odysseus, as we described at the end of the previous half, he has been left asleep beneath an olive tree on Ithaca. And when he wakes up, he, you know, you said, he has no idea where he is. Yeah. And so he fears the worst. He thinks, oh, no, this is another terrible trick. Poseidon is still kind of intervening to make my life hell. And so he trudges mournfully, we're told along the shore of the endlessly clamouring sea, kind of wondering, where am I? And then ahead of him, he sees a very handsome young shepherd lad. And so he hails the shepherd lad and says, where am I? And the shepherd boy answers, sir, you are in Ithaca. So you would think at this
在他到达伊萨卡之前。这对特勒马科斯来说是个坏消息。与此同时，正如我们在上一半结尾所描述的那样，奥德修斯被留在伊萨卡的一棵橄榄树下睡着了。当他醒来时，正如你所说，他根本不知道自己在哪里。是的。所以他担心最坏的情况。他想，噢不，这又是另一个可怕的诡计。波塞冬仍在干预，让我的生活陷入地狱。于是他悲伤地蹒跚而行，我们被告知他沿着无尽喧嚣的大海岸边走着，心想，我在哪里？然后在他前方，他看到了一个非常英俊的年轻牧羊人。于是他向牧羊人打招呼并问，我在哪里？牧羊人回答说，先生，你在伊萨卡。所以你可能会认为听到这个
news that Odysseus would, you know, I mean, he'd kind of explode with joy. But he's Odysseus. He doesn't. He disguises his delight and instead invokes the cunning in his heart and tells this absolute kind of cock and bull story about how he's actually a fugitive from Crete. I mean, it's kind of making things up just for the joy of making things up. The shepherd boy kind of listens to this story and then starts laughing. It's not a shepherd's boy's laugh. It's a woman's laugh. And she starts stroking him with her hand and materializes before him as this beautiful, towering woman. And it is, of course, Athena. And she says to him, a man would have to be crafty, a sly old fox to outdo all your tricks. She loves it. She can't get enough of a dicistice's a trick. she thinks it's great. So she basically explains to Odysseus the situation. This is what's going on
消息，奥德修斯会，你知道，他会因为喜悦而爆发。但他毕竟是奥德修斯。他没有。他掩饰了自己的喜悦，反而发挥了他心中的狡黠，编造了一个关于他是从克里特岛逃出来的逃犯的荒诞故事。我的意思是，他只是为了编造而编造。牧羊人听了这个故事，然后开始大笑。那不是牧羊人的笑声。那是女人的笑声。她开始用手抚摸他，并显现出她那美丽、高大的身姿。当然，她就是雅典娜。她对他说，一个人得非常狡猾，像只老狐狸，才能胜过你的诡计。她喜欢这样。她对奥德修斯的诡计乐此不疲。她觉得这太棒了。所以她基本上向奥德修斯解释了情况。这就是正在发生的事情
with all the suitors and this is how you're going to deal with it. And she has a plan, doesn't she? So she's basically going to disguise him. She's going to turn him into a beggar so that you will look vile in the eyes of all, the suitors and your wife as well as your child. Yes. And so she turns him into this kind of hideous old beggar. And then when she's done that, she says, go to the heart of the local swineherd Yumaeus, who Odysseus remembers from when he was in Ithaca 20 years before. And this is a man who is still loyal to Odysseus and to his house, so Telemachus and Penelope. And meanwhile, Athena tells Odysseus, I am going to go and I'm going to escort Telemachus safely back so that the suitors plan to murder him is foiled. And all of this is what duly comes to pass. So Odysseus, he's
关于所有的求婚者，这就是你将要处理的方式。她有一个计划，不是吗？所以她基本上要伪装他。她要把他变成一个乞丐，这样你在所有求婚者、你的妻子以及你的孩子眼中看起来都会很卑微。是的。于是她把他变成了这种丑陋的老乞丐。做完这些后，她说，去当地猪倌欧迈俄斯的住处，奥德修斯记得他，那是 20 年前他在伊萨卡时认识的人。这是一个仍然忠于奥德修斯及其家族，也就是特勒马科斯和佩涅洛佩的人。与此同时，雅典娜告诉奥德修斯，我要去护送特勒马科斯安全返回，这样求婚者们谋杀他的计划就会落空。所有这一切都如期发生了。所以奥德修斯，他
disguised as a beggar. He goes to Eumaeus's hut. Yumaeus treats him with great hospitality, with great generosity. He's just a humble swineherd, but again, he's kind of model of zania of kind of hospitality. It soon becomes clear to Odysseus that Eumaeus is utterly devoted to Odysseus's memory. He remains completely loyal to him. But despite this, Odysseus is Odysseus, so he doesn't reveal himself. Again, he comes up with some mad story, says he's a Cretan. And there's a bit of a joke here, I think, because in antiquity, the Cretan were always viewed as notorious liars. So Odysseus is kind of signaling that it's a lie. And he has this kind of great story saying that he'd served as a mercenary in Egypt, and then he'd
伪装成乞丐。他去了欧迈俄斯的茅屋。欧迈俄斯以极大的好客和慷慨对待他。他只是一个卑微的猪倌，但同样，他是“好客”的典范。奥德修斯很快就清楚地看出，欧迈俄斯对奥德修斯的记忆极其忠诚。他依然对他完全忠诚。但尽管如此，奥德修斯毕竟是奥德修斯，所以他没有暴露自己的身份。他再次编造了一些疯狂的故事，说自己是克里特人。这里有个小笑话，我想，因为在古代，克里特人总是被视为臭名昭著的骗子。所以奥德修斯是在暗示这是一个谎言。他编了一个很棒的故事，说他在埃及当过雇佣兵，然后他
had a run-in with Phoenician slave traders. And I think the thing that's interesting about this is that it clearly reflects the world in which Homer is writing this epic down rather than the age in which Odysseus is meant to have missed, because going to serve in Egypt as a mercenary or having run-ins with Phoenician slavers, this is much more appropriate. to the 8th or 7th centuries BC than to the, you know, to the bronze age. So it's like the register has kind of slipped. Yes, slightly.
和腓尼基奴隶贩子发生过冲突。我认为有趣的是，这清楚地反映了荷马写下这部史诗的世界，而不是奥德修斯本应错过的时代，因为去埃及当雇佣兵或与腓尼基奴隶贩子发生冲突，这更符合公元前 8 或 7 世纪，而不是青铜时代。所以这就像是语境有点错位了。是的，稍微有一点。
Yeah. And it may be that that's the whole point, you know, that this is a lie. You know, again, this is kind of quite postmodern that Odysseus is telling a lie. Homer is telling a lie. There's a kind of, you know, hall of mirrors there. Odysseus also having come up with this kind of, again, this cock and bull story to Emaeus, he tells Eumaeus, I have news. of your master, your missing master, Odysseus, he is on his way home. But Eumaeus, who's believed
是的。也许这正是重点，你知道，这是一个谎言。你知道，这再次显得相当后现代，奥德修斯在撒谎。荷马在撒谎。那里有一种镜厅的效果。奥德修斯在对欧迈俄斯编造了这个荒诞的故事后，告诉欧迈俄斯，我有你主人、你失踪的主人奥德修斯的消息，他正在回家的路上。但欧迈俄斯，他相信了
everything else that Odysseus has told him, all of which is a lie. This one thing which is the truth, Eumaeus does not believe it. And he tells Odysseus, the storm winds have snatched all his renown away. So Eumaeus basically thinks he is at the bottom of the sea. He is drowned and dead. Now, Telemachus has gone away and the suitors are waiting to ambush him. But Athenaeus, saves him, doesn't she, and brings him back safe and sound to Ithaca, he goes straight to Eumaeus, to Eumaeus's hut, but Emaeus is out, and now comes one of your favourite moments in the whole story. It's one of the great, great moments in Homer, because now is the meeting between the father and the son. So Athena, you know, she's disguised Odysseus as a beggar, all that goes. She restores
奥德修斯告诉他的所有其他事情，而所有这些都是谎言。唯独这一件是事实，欧迈俄斯却不相信。他告诉奥德修斯，风暴已经夺走了他所有的名声。所以欧迈俄斯基本上认为他已经沉入海底。他淹死了，死了。现在，特勒马科斯已经离开，求婚者们正等着伏击他。但雅典娜救了他，不是吗？并把他安全地带回了伊萨卡，他直接去了欧迈俄斯的茅屋，但欧迈俄斯出去了，现在是整个故事中你最喜欢的时刻之一。这是荷马作品中最伟大的时刻之一，因为现在是父子相见的时刻。所以雅典娜，你知道，她把奥德修斯伪装成乞丐，所有这些都过去了。她恢复了
him to his full stature and nobility, gives him a kind of little touch of stuff. so he looks even better than normal. And at first, Telemachus just cannot believe that this father, who, you know, he doesn't remember at all. He'd just been a baby when Odysseus left. He can't believe that Odysseus is back. But then, to quote Homer, he twined around his noble father, wailed as the tears pulled down, and a desperate longing for weeping welled up in both of them.
他原本的身材和高贵，给了他一点点神力。所以他看起来比平时更好。起初，特勒马科斯简直不敢相信这个父亲，你知道，他根本不记得他了。奥德修斯离开时他还是个婴儿。他不敢相信奥德修斯回来了。但随后，引用荷马的话，他缠绕着他高贵的父亲，随着泪水落下而哀号，一种绝望的哭泣渴望在他们两人心中涌动。
And so father and son, they embrace lots of sobbing. but there's a time when the sobbing has to stop because there is a lot of suitor killing to be done and this is now absolutely Odysseus's purpose and at first when he tells Telemachus this, Telemachus is very skeptical because remember there are 108 suitors and there's only the two of them but Odysse says, look, I'm a hero. I've killed a lot of people and also we have Athenaeer on our side and on top of that I am the cleverest man in the world and I have have a cunning plan. So here is my plan. I am going to infiltrate the palace in my brilliant disguise as a beggar. Your role Telemachus, when the moment comes, is to remove all the weapons
于是父子俩拥抱在一起，痛哭流涕。但哭泣总有停止的时候，因为还有很多求婚者需要被杀掉，这现在绝对是奥德修斯的目标。起初，当他告诉特勒马科斯这一点时，特勒马科斯非常怀疑，因为记住有 108 名求婚者，而他们只有两个人。但奥德修斯说，看，我是英雄。我杀过很多人，而且我们有雅典娜站在我们这边，最重要的是，我是世界上最聪明的人，我有一个狡猾的计划。所以这是我的计划。我将以乞丐的绝妙伪装潜入宫殿。特勒马科斯，你的任务是，当时机成熟时，移走所有挂在
that are hanging in the hall, and which the suitors might otherwise be able to use. You've got to remove them and conceal them. And what you should do is to leave just two swords, two spears, two shields, and that will be for our use. And then if we are armed, this. suitors aren't, we should be able to deal with them. I am confident of our ability to pull this off. So the excitement mounts are approaching the endgame now, the climax of the Odyssey. We'll start the very next morning, Tom. Take us into the story. Okay. The suitors have come back from their failed attempt to ambush Telemachus. Athena had managed to trick and fool them. And so now they've come back to Odysseus's palace and people may be wondering, well, you know, why don't they just kill Telemachus in
大厅里的武器，否则求婚者们可能会使用它们。你必须把它们移走并藏起来。你应该只留下两把剑、两支矛、两面盾牌，那是供我们使用的。然后如果我们武装起来，而求婚者们没有，我们就应该能对付他们。我对我们成功完成这件事充满信心。所以兴奋感在增加，我们现在接近结局了，也就是《奥德赛》的高潮。我们将在第二天早上开始，汤姆。带我们进入故事吧。好的。求婚者们从他们伏击特勒马科斯的失败尝试中回来了。雅典娜成功地欺骗并愚弄了他们。所以现在他们回到了奥德修斯的宫殿，人们可能会想，好吧，你知道，为什么他们不直接在
Odysseus' halls? Well, the reason for that is that they don't want to risk the anger of the gods, or indeed the people of Ithaca, by publicly murdering Odysse's son. And so that means that when Telemachus comes back from Eumaes's heart, after to meeting with his father, they leave him alone. You know, they kind of eye him warily, but they don't attack him. And so Telemachus is able to go to Penelope to talk with his mother and to tell her what he has learnt. in Sparta that Odysseus is alive. He does not tell her that Odysseus is back and that he has seen his father. So he proving himself a slight chip off the old block there. He also introduces her to a guy called Theo Clemenus, who is a wandering seer that he has brought back with him from Sparta. So it's the kind of thing you'd bring back from your Greek holiday. You'd pick up a wandering seer, I think, say, look what I've got. And Thaiclaminas also has amazing news. And Thericloenus says to Penelope, Odysseus, even now, back in the land of his father's already settled or on the move,
奥德修斯的宫殿里杀掉特勒马科斯呢？好吧，原因在于他们不想冒着激怒神灵的风险，或者激怒伊萨卡人民，去公开谋杀奥德修斯的儿子。所以这意味着当特勒马科斯从欧迈俄斯的茅屋回来，与父亲见面后，他们没有动他。你知道，他们只是警惕地看着他，但没有攻击他。所以特勒马科斯能够去见佩涅洛佩，与他的母亲交谈，并告诉她他在斯巴达学到的消息，即奥德修斯还活着。他没有告诉她奥德修斯已经回来了，也没有告诉她他已经见到了父亲。所以他证明了自己确实有其父之风。他还向她介绍了一个叫西奥克里门努斯的人，这是一个他从斯巴达带回来的流浪先知。所以这就像你从希腊度假带回来的东西。我想你会带回一个流浪先知，说，看我得到了什么。而西奥克里门努斯也有惊人的消息。西奥克里门努斯对佩涅洛佩说，奥德修斯，即使是现在，回到他父亲的土地上，已经安顿下来或正在路上，
learning of these wicked deeds is here. And he is sowing seeds of evil for all the suitors. But Penelope doesn't believe him, thinks that this cannot be true. She's been told so many lies over the years. She just can't bring herself to believe this news. But of course, it is true, because all the while, in his beggars disguise, Odysseus is approaching the gates of his palace. And on the way, he has a run-in with his old goat herd, a guy called Melantius. And Melantius is very much not like Emaeus. Melantius feels no loyalty to Odysseus, shows no courtesy to strangers. And so when he sees this old beggar, he gives him a kick and not realizing as he does say that, of course, he's kicking his own master. So that is something for Odysseus to bear in mind, the fact that his goat herd has kicked him.
得知了这些邪恶的行为，他就在这里。他正在为所有的求婚者播下邪恶的种子。但佩涅洛佩不相信他，认为这不可能是真的。多年来她听过太多的谎言。她只是无法让自己相信这个消息。但当然，这是真的，因为一直以来，奥德修斯都伪装成乞丐，正在接近他宫殿的大门。在路上，他和他的老山羊倌，一个叫梅兰修斯的人发生了冲突。梅兰修斯和欧迈俄斯完全不同。梅兰修斯对奥德修斯毫无忠诚，对陌生人也毫无礼貌。所以当他看到这个老乞丐时，他踢了他一脚，并没有意识到他踢的正是他自己的主人。所以这是奥德修斯需要记住的一点，他的山羊倌踢了他。
Will he wreck an awful vengeance? Well, time will tell. And now he comes up to the gates of his palace. And as he approaches them, he sees on the side of the road lying on a dung heap riddled with flies, an old scabby dog. And this dog is Argos, his beloved hunting dog, the dog that he had raised by hand as a puppy before he left for Troy. And as he walks past in his disguise as a beggar, nobody else recognizing him. Argos does recognize him, raises his head, pricks up his ears, wags his tail. And then, quote Homer, his fate, black death, took him in its grip.
他会进行可怕的报复吗？好吧，时间会证明一切。现在他来到了宫殿大门前。当他走近时，他看到路边躺在粪堆上，苍蝇环绕着一只长满疥疮的老狗。这只狗是阿尔戈斯，他心爱的猎狗，在他去特洛伊之前亲手养大的狗。当他伪装成乞丐走过时，没有其他人认出他。阿尔戈斯认出了他，抬起头，竖起耳朵，摇着尾巴。然后，引用荷马的话，他的命运，黑色的死亡，抓住了他。
the moment he saw Odysseus after 20 years had passed. So the single most tragic moment in the Greek history of relationships between pet owners and their pets. Very sad moment indeed, very famous. Yeah. So now, in his beggars garb, Odysseus, after 20 years away, goes into his palace. And Melantius, the goat her, mad from Melanthius now and who's got teamed up with the sister Melantho who is a concubine of one of the suitors they mock him don't they because they just think he's a beggar he's just a
在他 20 年后见到奥德修斯的那一刻。这是希腊历史上宠物主人与宠物关系中最悲惨的时刻。确实是一个非常悲伤的时刻，非常出名。是的。所以现在，穿着乞丐装的奥德修斯，在离开 20 年后，走进了他的宫殿。梅兰修斯，那个山羊倌，现在和他的妹妹梅兰托联手，梅兰托是其中一个求婚者的情妇，他们嘲笑他，不是吗？因为他们只认为他是个乞丐，他只是一个
yeah you know a tramp or whatever yeah they've got no time for him and also they got no time for penelope either neither of them loyal to Penelope in the slightest yeah a dish is disguised as a beggar is led into the hall and one of the suitors a guy called antinuous robert patterson i think in the Christopher Dolan film. He throws a footstool at Odysseus. And to be fair to the other suitors, they do think that this is poor behavior. They think, you know, you really shouldn't just throw stools at beggars. That will bring bad luck.
是的，你知道，一个流浪汉什么的，是的，他们没时间理他，他们也没时间理佩涅洛佩，他们两个对佩涅洛佩一点忠诚都没有。是的，伪装成乞丐的奥德修斯被带进大厅，其中一个求婚者，一个叫安提诺乌斯的人，我想是克里斯托弗·多兰电影里的罗伯特·帕特森。他向奥德修斯扔了一个脚凳。公平地说，其他求婚者确实认为这种行为很糟糕。他们认为，你知道，你真的不应该向乞丐扔凳子。那会带来厄运。
The gods will be angry. And so they make sure to give the old beggar some bread and meat and to kind of welcome him. And so the beggar is kind of sat at the side of the hall, the disguised Odysseus. And Penelope comes down and she notices him. And she thinks, he has the look of someone who might have wandered in far lands. Maybe he has news of my husband. And so that evening, she summons him for a private conversation. She doesn't recognize him.
神灵会愤怒的。所以他们确保给老乞丐一些面包和肉，并以某种方式欢迎他。于是乞丐坐在大厅的一侧，也就是伪装的奥德修斯。佩涅洛佩走下来，她注意到了他。她想，他看起来像个在远方流浪过的人。也许他有我丈夫的消息。于是那天晚上，她召见他进行私人谈话。她没有认出他。
But there's something about him that makes Penelope kind of confess to him all her grief, all her longing for her husband, and all her dread that she simply won't be able to keep these suitors at bay for much longer. And the disguised Odysseus replies to this by saying, well, I have news of your missing husband. I've seen him. And he gives a description of Odysseus that is so convincing that Penelope is persuaded that he's telling the truth. And she starts weeping the thought that perhaps Odysseus, her husband, really is out there. And the beggar says, you are right to have hope. Trust me, Odysseus is on his way. And Penelope is so happy about this that she says, look, you know, you're covered in scabs and dirt. Let's have you washed. And so she summons an elderly attendant in the palace, Euryclae, who had once been the nurse of Odysseus, so had knew Odysseus very well and intimately. Penelope orders Euriclaea to wash the feet of this old beggar. And Euraclair does so. And she sees that there is a scar on the thigh of this beggar.
但他身上有一种特质，让佩涅洛佩向他倾诉了她所有的悲伤、对丈夫所有的渴望，以及她担心自己无法再长时间抵挡这些求婚者的恐惧。伪装的奥德修斯回答说，好吧，我有你失踪丈夫的消息。我见过他。他给出的关于奥德修斯的描述非常令人信服，以至于佩涅洛佩相信他在说实话。她开始哭泣，想到也许奥德修斯，她的丈夫，真的还在外面。乞丐说，你有希望是对的。相信我，奥德修斯正在回来的路上。佩涅洛佩对此感到非常高兴，她说，看，你知道，你身上满是疥疮和污垢。让我们给你洗洗。于是她召集了宫殿里的一位年长侍女欧律克勒亚，她曾经是奥德修斯的奶妈，所以非常了解奥德修斯。佩涅洛佩命令欧律克勒亚给这个老乞丐洗脚。欧律克勒亚照做了。她看到这个乞丐的大腿上有一道伤疤。
And she recognizes it because this was a scar that Odysseus had got as a young man when he'd been out hunting bore with his grandfather. And Euryclare, because she had often washed Odysseus, of course, she now recognizes it. And she says to him, truly, you are Odysseus, dear child. And Odysseus said, be silent. Do not reveal who I am. puts his hand over her mouth, almost throttles her with his desperation not to have his secret betrayed. And so Euriclair keeps the secret. And he then goes back to his conversation with Penelope. And Penelope says, look, I've got a plan, best way that I can think of to keep the suitors at bay.
她认出了他，因为这是奥德修斯年轻时与祖父一起猎野猪时留下的伤疤。欧律克勒亚因为经常为奥德修斯洗澡，自然认出了他。她对他说，孩子，你真的是奥德修斯。奥德修斯说，安静，不要泄露我的身份。他捂住她的嘴，几乎要因为极度渴望不让秘密泄露而勒死她。于是欧律克勒亚保守了这个秘密。随后他回到与佩涅洛佩的谈话中。佩涅洛佩说，听着，我有一个计划，这是我能想到的阻挡求婚者的最好办法。
What I'm going to do, the next day, I am going to go down to them. And Odysseus, my missing husband, he has this great bow, which only he had ever been able to string. And I'm going to tell the suitors, whichever of you can string the bow and then shoot an arrow through 12 double-headed axes lined up in a row in the hall. was a favorite party trick of Odysseus is, if one of you can do that, then you will become my husband. And Odysseus hears this plan and he says, yeah, that is brilliant. That is a tremendous plan. Because of course, it completely dovetails with what he wants to do. And I think there is an ambiguity in Homer. There is the possibility that maybe Penelope has recognized him. Yeah. But she is a woman of tricks like he is. They're kind of start.
我打算第二天去见他们。我的丈夫奥德修斯失踪了，他有一张大弓，只有他能拉开。我会告诉求婚者，你们中谁能拉开这张弓，并射出一支箭穿过大厅里排成一行的12把双刃斧——这是奥德修斯最喜欢的派对把戏——如果你们中有人能做到，那他就会成为我的丈夫。奥德修斯听了这个计划，说，太棒了，这真是个绝妙的计划。因为这完全符合他想做的事。我认为荷马的作品中存在一种模糊性。有可能佩涅洛佩已经认出了他。是的，但她和他一样，是个诡计多端的女人。他们开始
to play this game where they're each telling tool stories to the other, not quite revealing. I mean, it's not absolutely stated, but I think part of the fascination of the scene is that that is clearly a possibility. The two of them now retire to bed. So Penelope, we're told, cried for her dear husband Odysseus until sweet sleep was poured onto her eyelids by Athena of the bright owl eyes. Meanwhile, Odysseus has gone down. He's lying in the hall and he can hear various slave girls in the household slipping out to have sex with the suitors who've taken them as concubines. And he's furious about this. He's anxious about how he's going to deal with the suitors. You know, is he taking on too much? And so he can't sleep. But then Athena appears to him, reassures him. And as she had
玩这种游戏，两人都在向对方讲述工具性的故事，却又不完全揭露真相。我的意思是，虽然没有明确说明，但我认为这一场景的魅力部分在于这显然是一种可能性。两人现在回房休息了。我们被告知，佩涅洛佩为她亲爱的丈夫奥德修斯哭泣，直到明眸女神雅典娜将甜美的睡眠倾注在她的眼睑上。与此同时，奥德修斯下楼了。他躺在大厅里，能听到家里的几个女奴溜出去与那些把她们当作妾室的求婚者发生关系。他对此感到愤怒。他担心自己该如何对付这些求婚者。你知道，他是不是承担了太多？所以他睡不着。但随后雅典娜出现在他面前，安慰了他。正如她之前
granted Penelope the gift of sleep, so Athena grants Odysseus the gift of sleep. And both husband and wife get the rest they're going to need for what is going to be a very, very momentous day. All right. So the fateful day has dawned at last. This is the day when there's going to be this contest with the bow and the axe for the hand of Penelope. The suitors are in great form.
赐予佩涅洛佩睡眠的礼物一样，雅典娜也赐予了奥德修斯睡眠的礼物。夫妻俩都得到了他们为即将到来的极其重大的日子所需要的休息。好了，决定性的日子终于到来了。这一天将举行用弓和斧头争夺佩涅洛佩之手的比赛。求婚者们状态极佳。
They're feasting. They're fighting with each other. They're throwing bones at the beggar, who is, of course, Odysseus. Yeah. But Odysseus and Telemachus are getting ready for what they know will be a decisive moment. So Temaikas has taken weapons out of the hall, hasn't he?
他们在大吃大喝，互相打闹。他们向那个乞丐扔骨头，而那个乞丐当然就是奥德修斯。是的，但奥德修斯和特勒马科斯正在为他们所知道的决定性时刻做准备。所以特勒马科斯已经把武器从大厅里拿走了，不是吗？
And they have Eumaeus on hand, who's the one guy that they can trust. There's also another cowherd, I think. Is that right? Yeah, so Eumaeus is the pig herd, the swineherd. And this guy is the cowherd filotius. He's also loyal. And so Odysseus hasn't yet revealed who he is to either of these guys, but he knows that he can trust them.
他们有欧迈俄斯在场，这是他们唯一能信任的人。我想还有另一个牧牛人，对吧？是的，欧迈俄斯是养猪人，而这个人是牧牛人菲洛提俄斯。他也非常忠诚。所以奥德修斯还没有向这两个人透露他的身份，但他知道他可以信任他们。
So they're on hand. And then we've got the wandering seer who Telemachus had brought back from his holiday to Sparta with him. And he pops up and the suit is all having a great time and then he tells them what's coming. Blood is spattered all over the walls and the beautiful rafters. The entry is filled with ghosts, the courtyard filled with them too, which isn't at all the kind of thing that you want if you're having a great time. So the hour arrives. Penelope enters the hall and she is holding. the great bow and quiver of Odysseus and behind her a train of her women holding the 12 axes made of bronze and iron. Penelope announces to the suitors her decision that whoever can
所以他们都在场。还有特勒马科斯从斯巴达度假带回来的那个流浪先知。他突然出现，求婚者们正玩得开心，然后他告诉了他们即将发生的事情。鲜血溅满了墙壁和美丽的椽子。入口处挤满了鬼魂，庭院里也挤满了鬼魂，这可不是你在玩得开心时想看到的情景。于是时刻到了。佩涅洛佩走进大厅，手里拿着奥德修斯的大弓和箭袋，身后跟着一队女仆，拿着12把青铜和铁制的斧头。佩涅洛佩向求婚者宣布了她的决定，谁能
string the bow and shoot an arrow through the axe heads will become her husband. And Telemachus then sets the axes in a line along the hall and the suitors all step forward. And the suitors all step forward in turn to try and string the bow, all 108 of them, and not one of them has the strength to string the bow. Meanwhile, as the suitors are doing this, Odysseus has taken Eumaeus, the loyal swineherd, and Philotius, the loyal cowherd, outside, and at last now, he reveals his true identity. And they think this is brilliant, you know, they fall to their knees, absolutely delighted, sobbing with joy. And he gives them specific tasks. You mayas is to bring him the bow when the time comes, and Philotius is to lock the gates of the hall
拉开弓并射出一支箭穿过斧头，谁就将成为她的丈夫。特勒马科斯随后将斧头在大厅里排成一行，求婚者们轮流上前尝试拉弓，108个人中没有一个人有力量拉开弓。与此同时，当求婚者们这样做时，奥德修斯把忠诚的养猪人欧迈俄斯和忠诚的牧牛人菲洛提俄斯带到外面，终于揭示了他的真实身份。他们觉得这太棒了，他们跪倒在地，欣喜若狂，喜极而泣。他给了他们具体的任务。欧迈俄斯要在时机成熟时把弓带给他，而菲洛提俄斯要锁上大厅的门
so that no one can escape or summon help. Inside the hall, the suitors have all been trying to string this massive bow and failing. And so Odysseus goes back inside the hall and he makes a suggestion. He says, well, why do we have a go tomorrow? At dawn, the God will grant victory to whomesoever he wishes. And in the meanwhile, he says, while we're waiting, because you're all obviously now at a bit of a loose end, why don't I have a try? You'll find it. Entertaining, watching me, a stooped old beggar having a go. Where's the harm? And at this, the suitors explode in indignation. And Antinuous, who, you know, the guy who'd chucked the stool at him right at the beginning, so the most boorish of all the suitors, he rounds on Odysseus disguised as the beggar
这样就没人能逃跑或寻求帮助。在大厅里，求婚者们都在尝试拉开这把巨大的弓，但都失败了。于是奥德修斯回到大厅，提出了一个建议。他说，为什么我们明天再试呢？黎明时分，神会把胜利赐予他所希望的人。与此同时，他说，在我们等待的时候，因为你们显然现在没什么事做，为什么不让我试一试呢？看着我这个弯腰驼背的老乞丐尝试一下，你们会觉得很有趣的。有什么坏处呢？听到这话，求婚者们愤怒地爆发了。安提诺俄斯，就是那个一开始向他扔凳子的人，也就是所有求婚者中最粗鲁的一个，他转向伪装成乞丐的奥德修斯
with insults. But first Penelope and then Telemachus, tell Antinous, show some manners. You are in our hall. And Telemachus tells Penelope, go to your rooms. So again, you know, he's definitely manned up. I think it's fair to say. And then he gives a secret nod to Eumaeus. This is the signal to, you know, we're about to go. And so Eumaeus, as he'd been instructed to go, goes over, picks up the bow and gives it to Odysseus. And Odysseus, tests the bow, he scans it, Homer says that he almost caresses it, and then abruptly to the absolute stupefaction of the watching suitors, he strings it. And he plucks the string to test his pitch. And as he does so, we're told, Zeus sends a flash of lightning from the clear blue sky
进行侮辱。但先是佩涅洛佩，然后是特勒马科斯，告诉安提诺俄斯，表现得礼貌一点。你们在我们的厅堂里。特勒马科斯告诉佩涅洛佩，回你的房间去。所以，你知道，他确实变得更有男子气概了。我认为这样说很公平。然后他给欧迈俄斯使了个眼色。这是信号，意思是我们要开始了。于是欧迈俄斯按照指示，走过去拿起弓递给奥德修斯。奥德修斯测试了弓，他仔细打量着它，荷马说他几乎是在爱抚它，然后突然间，在围观的求婚者目瞪口呆的注视下，他拉开了弓。他拨动弓弦测试音调。就在他这样做的时候，我们被告知，宙斯从晴朗的蓝天中降下一道闪电
overhead. And then Odysseus takes an arrow and he knocks it and he draws and he draws and he lets fly and the arrow passes through all 12 of the axe heads. Yes, the bronze-weighted shaft sailed straight through them. And at this point, Telemachus reaches for his sword and spear and Odysseus strips off his rags, and he aims an arrow at Antinuas the worst behaved of all the suitors, and he lets fly. And Antinous, who is obliviously lifting a great golden goblet to his lips as all this is happening, is struck directly in the throat and blood spurts out in a great jet. It's a very cinematic description from Homer. And at the spectacle of this is complete pandemonium.
头顶上方。然后奥德修斯拿出一支箭，搭在弦上，拉开，拉开，然后射出，箭穿过了所有12个斧头。是的，青铜箭杆径直穿过了它们。此时，特勒马科斯伸手去拿他的剑和矛，奥德修斯脱掉了他的破烂衣服，他瞄准了所有求婚者中表现最差的安提诺俄斯，射出了箭。安提诺俄斯在这一切发生时正漫不经心地把一个巨大的金杯举到嘴边，他的喉咙被直接击中，鲜血喷涌而出。这是荷马非常电影化的描述。看到这一幕，现场彻底陷入了混乱。
And the suitors all think that the beggar must have done it by accident. I mean, surely this is the only explanation. But no, because now comes the moment when Odysseus announces himself to the whole. You dogs, you never imagine that I would make my way home from the country. of the Trojans, look how you've wasted my house, how you've forced yourselves upon the slave women in bed, how while I was still alive, but out of sight, you courted my wife. And the slaughter begins and it is terrible and it is total. But there is a chance for the suitors, isn't there? Because you'd mentioned earlier this goat herd Melanthius, who would identify himself as an
求婚者们都认为一定是那个乞丐不小心做到的。我的意思是，这肯定是唯一的解释。但不是，因为现在是奥德修斯向所有人宣布自己身份的时刻。你们这些狗东西，你们从没想过我会从特洛伊人的土地上回到家。看看你们是如何浪费我的房子，如何强迫女奴与你们同床，如何在我还活着但不在视线范围内时追求我的妻子。屠杀开始了，这很可怕，而且是彻底的。但求婚者们还有机会，不是吗？因为你之前提到过那个牧羊人墨兰提俄斯，他在奥德修斯进来时踢了他，从而暴露了自己是一个
absolute villain by kicking Odysseus when he was on his way in. And this, actually slips out of the hall and starts to bring them weapons and armour, doesn't he? He does. But fortunately for Odysseus, he's rumbled by Yemeyas and Philotius. And they truss him up and they lift him up to the roof beams and they leave him hanging there. And this portends nothing good for Melanthius. And meanwhile, the slaughter is continuing in the hall. And Athena has turned up for the fun. And she's not there to help Odysseus, but basically to goad him on and tell him to kill even faster. And she materialises first as mentor. So this old friend of Odysseus, which was the form that she'd appeared to Telemachus at the beginning of this episode. And then she turns into a swallow
彻头彻尾的恶棍。他实际上溜出了大厅，开始给他们拿武器和盔甲，不是吗？他确实这么做了。但幸运的是，对于奥德修斯来说，他被欧迈俄斯和菲洛提俄斯发现了。他们把他捆起来，吊在屋顶的横梁上，让他挂在那里。这对墨兰提俄斯来说不是什么好兆头。与此同时，大厅里的屠杀仍在继续。雅典娜也为了凑热闹出现了。她不是来帮助奥德修斯的，而是为了激励他，告诉他杀得更快些。她首先化身为门托尔，也就是奥德修斯的这位老朋友，这也是她在本集开头向特勒马科斯显现的形式。然后她变成了一只燕子
and she perches on the great smoke-blackened roof beam of the hall. And this is something that she loves doing. She loves taking on the form of a bird, and particularly when there are spectacles of bloodshed. So in the Iliad she had disguised herself as a vulture and there are descriptions of her kind of shivering with delight at the spectacle of blood being spilled. And spectacles of blood being spilled is absolutely what she gets now in the hall of Odysseus. So tremendous violence, tremendous slaughter, all the suitors end up dead. And the metaphor that Homer uses is that of fish being dragged onto a beach in nets and speared. And there's an echo there of what had happened to Odysseus's men in the harbour of the Lestrogonians, where the Lestrogonians had gone and speared all his
栖息在大厅被烟熏黑的巨大横梁上。这是她喜欢做的事情。她喜欢化身为鸟，特别是在有流血场面的时候。所以在《伊利亚特》中，她伪装成秃鹫，书中描述她因看到鲜血流淌而颤抖着欢呼。而鲜血流淌的场面正是她现在在奥德修斯大厅里所看到的。所以，巨大的暴力，巨大的屠杀，所有的求婚者最终都死了。荷马使用的隐喻是像被网拖上岸并被刺死的鱼。这与奥德修斯的人在莱斯特律戈涅斯港遭遇的事情相呼应，当时莱斯特律戈涅斯人刺死了他所有的
men. So the suitors are wiped out, but they are not the only victims of Odysseus's terrible vengeance. Because he, when the slaughter is done, he demands to know of Euryclae, his old nurse, which of the servant girls have been sleeping with the suitors? And Euraclera replies, well, there were 12 of them. So it's a bit like post-Vici France. You know, they are female collaborators, horizontal. That's exactly the analogy I thought of. And their fate is horrible, isn't it?
人。所以求婚者们被消灭了，但他们并不是奥德修斯可怕复仇的唯一受害者。因为当屠杀结束后，他要求他的老奶妈欧律克勒亚指出哪些女仆与求婚者睡过觉。欧律克勒亚回答说，有12个。所以这有点像维希法国后的情况。你知道，她们是女性通敌者，水平方向的。这正是我所想到的类比。她们的命运很可怕，不是吗？
Yes. So they are told to carry out the corpses of the suitors, among them they're dead lovers. And then to clean the hall, the tables, the benches. Meanwhile, Telemachus has strung a ship's cable from a pillar to a beam and from this cable, the maids are hanged. To quote Homer, a horrible description, just as when some thrushes with slender wings or some doves go crashing into a snare. And we're told that as they are throttled, the girls' feet twitch.
是的。所以她们被命令搬走求婚者的尸体，其中包括她们死去的爱人。然后清理大厅、桌子和长凳。与此同时，特勒马科斯从柱子到横梁拉了一根船缆，女仆们就被吊在这根缆绳上。引用荷马的话，这是一个可怕的描述，就像一些细翅画眉或鸽子撞进陷阱一样。我们被告知，当她们被勒死时，女孩们的脚在抽搐。
And then Homer says, but not for very long. I wonder if Tom Holland's going to be doing this in the film, because he's Telemachus, isn't he? I mean, it's genuinely interesting to see whether the slaughter of the servant girls included. I can't imagine Matt Damon doing it, but who knows? It'll always be so interesting to see whether Melanthius features as a character in the Nolan film, because he is given a particularly horrible punishment, so his nose and ears are sliced off, his genitals are cut off and fed to dogs, and his hands and feet are amputated. And Homer does not specify whether he dies of this mutilations, or whether he's just left to eke out of hideous.
然后荷马说，但没过多久。我不知道汤姆·赫兰德在电影里会不会演这一段，因为他是特勒马科斯，不是吗？我的意思是，看看女仆的屠杀是否包括在内确实很有趣。我无法想象马特·达蒙会这样做，但谁知道呢？看看墨兰提俄斯是否会作为诺兰电影中的一个角色出现总是很有趣的，因为他受到了特别可怕的惩罚，他的鼻子和耳朵被割掉，生殖器被切掉喂狗，手脚被截肢。荷马没有具体说明他是否死于这些残害，还是只是被留下来苟延残喘。
living as a beggar. Yeah. What would one prefer? I don't know. There is a lot of brutality in this world. But Euryklaea, I mean, she thinks it's all brilliant. She couldn't be happier, the spectacle of all this slaughter and bloodshed and castration. And in fact, she's almost laughing for joy as she rushes up to tell her mistress, Penelope, what has been going on.
像乞丐一样活着。是的。人们会更喜欢哪种结局？我不知道。这个世界上有很多残暴。但欧律克勒亚，我的意思是，她认为这一切都很棒。她再高兴不过了，看到这一切屠杀、流血和阉割的场面。事实上，当她冲去告诉她的女主人佩涅洛佩发生了什么事时，她几乎在欢笑。
But Penelope still can't quite believe it. Or does she? Is she still playing games? And she comes downstairs and she gazes at Odysseus. And Homer says that she is torn by uncertainty. Sometimes as she stared at him, she seemed to see his face, but sometimes she failed to recognize him dressed in vile rags. And Telemachus can't believe this. How can his mother possibly doubt that she is gazing at her husband, Telemachus's father? But Penelope says, look, if he truly is Odysseus, we will know each other in our own ways. For we, you know, we have signs. We have. We have. have secrets that are known only to the two of us. And Odysseus smiles at this. And again, I think there's this sense that they're playing the kind of games that perhaps they played before he left for Troy. And so he says, run me a bath. And Penelope obeys and a bath is run for him. And then when
但佩涅洛佩仍然不太相信。或者她相信了？她还在玩游戏吗？她走下楼，凝视着奥德修斯。荷马说她被不确定性所折磨。有时她盯着他看，似乎看到了他的脸，但有时她又认不出穿着破烂衣服的他。特勒马科斯无法相信这一点。他的母亲怎么可能怀疑她正在凝视着她的丈夫、特勒马科斯的父亲呢？但佩涅洛佩说，听着，如果他真的是奥德修斯，我们会以我们自己的方式认出对方。因为我们，你知道，我们有标志。我们有。我们有只有我们两人才知道的秘密。奥德修斯对此微笑。我再次认为，他们有一种感觉，就像他在去特洛伊之前玩的那种游戏。所以他说，给我准备洗澡水。佩涅洛佩照做了，洗澡水准备好了。然后当
he steps out from the bath, we're told that Athena poured great beauty upon his head. But Penelope, She's still not welcoming him back as her husband. And Odysseus says, your heart is made of iron. You are the hardest of women. But Penelope says, I don't care. I'm not going to be taken for a fool. And she says to Eureclair, go and move the bed out of our bridal chamber, the chamber that Odysseus, my husband, built with his own.
他从浴缸里走出来时，我们被告知雅典娜将巨大的美貌倾注在他的头上。但佩涅洛佩，她仍然没有欢迎他作为她的丈夫回来。奥德修斯说，你的心是铁做的。你是最冷酷的女人。但佩涅洛佩说，我不在乎。我不会被当作傻瓜。她对欧律克勒亚说，去把床从我们的新房里搬出来，那是我丈夫奥德修斯亲手建造的房间。
own hands. And when a dish is hears this, he explodes. And he says, what do you mean? This bed can't be moved because when I made it myself, I fashioned one of the four boasts out of a living olive tree. And I had then built the bed chamber around this living olive tree, around this bed that I've made out of it, adorning it within lays of gold and silver and ivory. So in other words, the only way that the the bed could be moved is if someone had cut the living trunk of the tree. And this is something known only to Odysseus, only to Penelope. And so when he says this at last, Penelope's knees give way and her heart as well. And she embraces him and she kisses him and she is struck in her joy by the last of the poem's great similes. And it reverses what had happened because now it is
亲手建造的。当奥德修斯听到这话时，他爆发了。他说，你是什么意思？这张床不能移动，因为当我亲自制作它时，我用一棵活的橄榄树做成了四个床柱之一。然后我围绕这棵活的橄榄树，围绕我用它做成的床建造了卧室，用金、银和象牙镶嵌装饰它。所以换句话说，移动这张床的唯一方法就是有人砍断了树的活树干。这是只有奥德修斯和佩涅洛佩才知道的事情。所以当他终于说出这一点时，佩涅洛佩的双膝发软，心也软了。她拥抱他，亲吻他，她在喜悦中被这首诗最后一个伟大的明喻所震撼。它扭转了之前发生的事情，因为现在是
Penelope who is being compared to the sailor lost at sea. She, Homer says, is like a shipwrecked sailor crusted in brine who at last treads on dry land after escaping from disaster. And the great moment of husband and wife being joined together after all these adventures, all these many, many years of absence, at last it arrives. And they retire to bed and Athena holds back the coming of the dawn so that they can enjoy the ultimate reunion. And the amazing thing is, again, it's another kind of postmodern kind of meta aspect of the poem that they have time because Athena has pushed the dawn back for the pair of them to catch up on what the other has been doing. And so Odysseus basically tells the story of his adventures, so essentially what we covered
佩涅洛佩被比作在海上迷失的船夫。荷马说，她就像一个在海上遇难的船夫，身上结满了盐渍，在逃离灾难后终于踏上了陆地。夫妻在经历了所有这些冒险、所有这些漫长的离别岁月后终于团聚的伟大时刻，终于到来了。他们回房休息，雅典娜推迟了黎明的到来，这样他们就能享受最终的重逢。令人惊奇的是，这又是这首诗的另一种后现代元叙事层面，他们有时间，因为雅典娜为他们推迟了黎明，让他们补上对方所经历的一切。所以奥德修斯基本上讲述了他的冒险故事，也就是我们所涵盖的内容。
in episode one. And Penelope tells Odysseus what she's been like. to, so basically the outline of this episode. So in other words, the first people to narrate the action, the story of the Odyssey are Odysseus and Penelope themselves. I'm the first people to hear it. And the first people to hear it, although obviously not the last. So the appeal of the Odyssey, Tom, what do you think it boils down to? Because it's obviously the product of a very specific time and place, and yet it's proved so enduring and so influential on Western literary culture and more generally. I think it's exactly that fusion. I think it's the fact that it has gods, it features famous monsters.
在第一集中，佩涅洛佩讲述了她的经历。基本上这就是本集的梗概。换句话说，奥德赛和佩涅洛佩本人是讲述奥德赛故事的第一批叙述者，也是第一批听众，当然他们肯定不是最后一批。汤姆，你认为奥德赛的魅力归根结底是什么？因为它显然是特定时间和地点的产物，却在西方文学文化乃至更广泛的领域中展现出如此持久且深远的影响力。我认为正是这种融合，因为它有神灵，还有著名的怪物。
Speaking for myself, I loved that as a child. That was the quality that I loved. But also, to be honest, I loved the violence of it and the murderous quality of Odysseus as well as the cunning aspect of him. People, I think, enjoy that in stories. There's a savagery to it that's often lost in children's versions, I think. A cruelty. But also, I think the basic plot of it is so adaptable.
就我个人而言，我小时候很喜欢这一点。这就是我所钟爱的特质。但老实说，我也喜欢其中的暴力色彩，以及奥德修斯那种杀戮的本性和他狡诈的一面。我认为人们在故事中很享受这一点。我认为儿童版本中往往丢失了一种野蛮感，一种残酷感。但同时，我认为它的基本情节非常具有可塑性。
It can be retold in so many ways, and it has been retold in lots of ways. I mean, there are elements of it in Virgil's poem The Aeneid. That in turn influences Dante, who describes Odysseus. After he has returned to Ithaca, he ends up bored, and he sets sail for his last great voyage to the ends of the world. And that is then reworked by Tennyson in the 19th century in his great poem Ulysses. And I think it's a perfect way to end this because it describes a hero who will never come to rest, who will always be embarking on fresh adventures. And you can see that now with the Christopher Nolan film.
它可以以多种方式重述，事实上也确实被重述过很多次。我的意思是，维吉尔的史诗《埃涅阿斯纪》中就有它的影子。这反过来又影响了但丁，他在作品中描述了奥德修斯。在回到伊萨卡岛后，奥德修斯感到厌倦，于是他启航进行了最后一次伟大的航行，前往世界的尽头。后来，丁尼生在19世纪的伟大诗作《尤利西斯》中对此进行了重构。我认为这是结束本集的完美方式，因为它描述了一位永不歇息、永远踏上新冒险旅程的英雄。你现在在克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影中也能看到这一点。
There was the Ray Fines film as well, which describes his homecoming. And that is just one of a kind of endless number of reworking that continue to, to be made in film, in fiction, in poetry. So let's end it with Tennyson's Ulysses Odysseus, saying how he is going to leave on one last final voyage. Though much has taken, much abides, and though we are not now that strength which in old days moved earth and heaven, that to which we are, we are,
还有拉尔夫·费因斯的电影，也描述了他的归乡之旅。这只是在电影、小说和诗歌中不断涌现的无数重构作品之一。那么，让我们以丁尼生的《尤利西斯》中奥德修斯的话来结束吧，他说他将踏上最后一次航行。尽管我们已失去许多，但仍有许多留存；虽然我们已不再是往昔那般能撼动天地，但我们依然是我们，
one equal temper of heroic hearts, made weak by time and fate, but strong in will, to strive, to seek, to find, and not to yield. Well, thank you, Tennyson. And thank you, Tom, for what's been an epic journey, an odyssey, dare I say? Literally so. Through this most influential of all great stories.
拥有英雄般坚毅的灵魂，虽被时间和命运削弱，但意志坚定，去奋斗，去探索，去寻找，永不屈服。好吧，感谢丁尼生。也感谢汤姆，感谢你带我们走过这段史诗般的旅程，或者我敢说，这是一场奥德赛之旅？确实如此。感谢你带我们领略了所有伟大故事中最具影响力的一部。
So next week, we will be somewhere very different. We will be in late 1880s, Fandescik, Vienna for the Murder Suicide Mystery of Myeling. And Restis History Club members can get both of those episodes on Monday. You won't have to wait. And by the way, we are running our summer sale. So if you want to join the Restis History Club, this is the moment. For a limited time only, you can get 20% off an annual membership using the code summer 26. And that offer is valid until August the 31st.
下周，我们将去往一个非常不同的地方。我们将回到1880年代末的维也纳，探究梅耶林惨案的自杀谜团。“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员周一就可以收听这两集，无需等待。顺便说一下，我们正在进行夏季促销。如果你想加入“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，现在正是时候。在有限时间内，使用代码summer 26购买年度会员可享受八折优惠。该优惠有效期至8月31日。
So on that, Bombshell, thank you very much. Tom, thank you, everybody. And goodbye. Goodbye. If you want a $3,000 a month payday for life, what would you feel free to do? Maybe take a long weekend, every weekend, or try a bunch of new hobbies. Would you feel free to upgrade and listen ad-free? Don't worry, we get it.
那么，关于这个重磅消息，非常感谢。汤姆，谢谢你，大家再见。再见。如果你想要一份每月3000美元的终身收入，你会怎么做？也许每个周末都休个长假，或者尝试各种新爱好。你想过升级并享受无广告收听吗？别担心，我们理解。
Every $20 ticket could win you $3,000 a month for life and supports life-saving cancer research at the Princess Margaret. Feel free to buy your payday for life ticket today. Raffle number 155-214. Please play responsibly. Hello there. It's Al Murray. here and James Holland there, hosts of the Second World War Pod, we have ways of making you talk. Alan and I have been on The Rest Is History a few times now, talking all things World War II with Tom and Dominic.
每张20美元的彩票都有机会让你赢得每月3000美元的终身收入，并支持玛格丽特公主医院的救命癌症研究。请立即购买你的终身收入彩票。抽奖编号155-214。请理性参与。大家好，我是阿尔·默里，那位是詹姆斯·霍兰德，我们是二战播客《我们有办法让你开口》的主持人。艾伦和我已经多次做客《历史的其余部分》，与汤姆和多米尼克讨论二战的一切。
If you've enjoyed their recent topics on 20th century history, then we have good news for you. Yes, that's right, Jim. We have our own show, all about the fascinating history of World War II. Every Tuesday and Thursday, WW2 Pod, we have ways of making you talk, discusses the fascinating people, amazing innovations and terrible tragedies of this most pivotal period in human history. Yeah, and the bottom line is, other history has absolutely nothing on this. This past year alone, we've done series on visionary US presidents
如果你喜欢他们最近关于20世纪历史的话题，那么我们有好消息告诉你。是的，没错，吉姆。我们有自己的节目，专门讲述二战迷人的历史。每周二和周四，二战播客《我们有办法让你开口》都会探讨人类历史上这一关键时期迷人的人物、惊人的创新和可怕的悲剧。是的，归根结底，其他历史与此相比根本不算什么。仅在过去一年里，我们就制作了关于富有远见的美国总统的系列节目，
like FDR and Truman, HMS Hood v Bismarck, and Japan's Road to War. We've also explored daring night raids behind enemy lines like Bruneval and the nerve-wracking Atlantic convoys. And right now, we're doing the truly Titanic Operation Barbarossa,
比如富兰克林·罗斯福和杜鲁门、胡德号对阵俾斯麦号，以及日本的战争之路。我们还探索了像布吕内瓦尔突袭那样深入敌后的胆大夜袭，以及令人神经紧绷的大西洋护航行动。而现在，我们正在讲述真正宏大的巴巴罗萨行动，
the Nazi German invasion of the Soviet Union in the summer of 1941. So now is a great time to subscribe and get into the action. Search, We Have Ways, wherever you get your podcasts. That's we have ways wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Mary Beard. And I'm Josephine Quinn. At the rest is fest this September, we're putting on a show that can only be described
即1941年夏天纳粹德国入侵苏联的行动。所以现在是订阅并参与其中的好时机。在任何你获取播客的地方搜索“We Have Ways”。就是“We Have Ways”，无论你在哪里收听播客。我是玛丽·比尔德。我是约瑟芬·奎因。在今年九月的“历史的其余部分”艺术节上，我们将呈现一场只能被描述为
as an iconoclastic romp through the ancient world. We're talking about leaders behaving badly. Emperors putting their horses in charge. cities built by asylum seekers and empires getting their comeuppance. There will be some proper myth busting. But we'll also be asking why these myths matter, even when we know they're wrong. So if you love your ancient history and you're free on September 6th, get your ticket now and join us at London's South Bank Centre. Tickets are on sale now.
对古代世界进行偶像破坏式狂欢的演出。我们将讨论行为不端的领导人、让马匹担任官职的皇帝、由寻求庇护者建立的城市，以及遭受报应的帝国。我们将进行一些真正的神话破除。但我们也会探讨为什么这些神话即使在被证明错误后依然重要。所以，如果你热爱古代历史，并且9月6日有空，现在就买票加入我们在伦敦南岸中心的活动吧。门票现已发售。
Just visit southbankcentre.com.com.uk. That's southbank centre.combe.com.uk. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
只需访问southbankcentre.com.uk。那是southbankcentre.com.uk。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。